bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat hier soir après un ultime vote du
Sénat le Parlement français a donc
adopté son plan d'aide d'urgence à la
Grèce il prévoit des prês bilatéraux
d'un montant de 16,8 milliards d'euros
sur une période de 3 ans pour l'année
2010 cela représente 3,9 milliards de
comme à l'Assemblée nationale en début
de semaine l'UMP et le PS ont voté pour
ce texte en invoquant le sauvetage de la
grèe et de l'euro et comme à l'Assemblée
les communistes ont voté contre ce texte
c'est donc une partie de l'examen de ce
second projet de loi de finance
rectificative que je vous propose de
suivre tout de suite bonne matinée à
tous sur Public
Sénat bien mes chers collègues l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion du projet
de loi adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
de finan rectificatif pour 2000 201 dans
la discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Christine Lagarde ministre de
l'économie de l'industrie et de
l'emploi monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
projet de loi de finance rectificative
que le gouvernement vous présente
aujourd'hui revê un caractère unique il
s'agit de répondre une crise sans
véritable précédent qui menaçait
d'entraîner certaines économies au bord
du précipice les raisons des difficultés
de la Grèce sont connu tout d'abord
depuis le début de la crise économique
et financière l'accès au financement
pour certains pays européens s'était
rétréci pour la Grèce en particulier
au-delà de ces problèmes structurels la
Grèce a dû faire face à un vrai problème
bien spécifique un problème de
crédibilité la prévision de déficit
public est en effet passée de 3, 7 % en
avril 2009 à 6 % en septembre 2009 puis
à 12,5 % en octobre 2009 soit un mois
plus tard puis à 12,7 % en janvier et
enfin à 13,6 % en avril 2010 dans ce
contexte les marchés se sont révélés de
plus en plus préoccupés de la situation
budgétaire grecque les observateurs
estimant que le risque d'un défaut
éventuel de la Grèce s'était accru de
façon
significative les les États membres de
la zone euro ne pouvaient bien
évidemment pas rester sans rien faire
face à cette situation qui pouvait à
terme porter un grave préjudice à notre
monnaie
commune la stabilité de la zone euro
étant menacée les États-membres la
France en tête se sont fortement
mobilisé tout d'abord au niveau européen
les chefs d'État et de gouvernement se
sont réunis dès le 11 février à titre
informel puis à nouveau lors du Conseil
formel cette fois-ci européen des 25 et
26 mars pour je cite préserver la
stabilité financière de la zone euro
dans son ensemble le 11 avril les
ministres des Finances de la zone euro
réunis en Eurogroup précisaient les
modalités techniques du plan de soutien
financier à la greque quelques jours
seulement avant la demande officielle de
la Grèce d'activer le plan de soutien en
sa faveur le 23
avril dimanche dernier au matin le
gouvernement grec a annoncé lors d'un
conseil des ministres extraordinaires
qu'il s'engageait à respecter le
programme négocié avec la Commission
européenne le Fond Monétaire
International et la Banque centrale
européenne l'ensemble de ce dispositif
bien entendu repose sur un équilibre
d'une part des financements qui sont
consenti par l'ensemble des pays
européens et par le Fond Monétaire
International et d'autre part des
efforts en matière de rigueur budgétaire
et un véritable plan d'austérité dont je
vous indique d'ors et déjà puisque le
vote vient d'êre être acquis au
parlement grec dont je vous indique donc
que la représentation nationale grecque
vient de
l'approuver ce dispositif prévoit je
l'indiquais un soutien financier massif
puisque l'enveloppe totale pour une
période triénal est de 110 milliards
d'euros sur ces 110 milliards d'euros 80
seront pris en charge par les pays
membres de la zone euro à l'exclusion
bien sûr de la Grèce et 30 milliards
seront pris en charge par le Fond
Monétaire
International ce projet de loi de
finance rectificative ouvre donc pour
2010 un total de 16,8 milliards d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement sur un
programme créé à cet effet à l'origine
le projet de loi de finance
rectificative prévoyait la mise à
disposition d'un montant de 30 milliards
d'euros pour la première année du plan
de soutien c'était la négociation
initiale qui avait été conclu sans
l'intervention massive du Fond monétaire
international à la fois pour le
financement et pour la construction du
programme la réunion de l'Eurogroupe à
laquelle j'ai participé dimanche
après-midi a décidé d'activer le plan de
soutien financier à la Grèce négocié au
cours des 10 jours qui avaient précédé
cette réunion avec le fond avec la
Commission et avec la Banque centrale
européenne pour un montant je vous
l'indiquais de 110 milliards d'euros
réparti sur 3 ans l'amendement du
Gouvernement adopté mardi par
l'Assemblée nationale vise ainsi à
refléter l'engagement de la France non
plus sur la seule première année du
programme telle qu'initialement
considéré mais sur les trois années
entière en accord avec la clé de
répartition au capital de la Banque
centrale européenne de chacun des États
membres hors Grèce soit 20,97 % pour la
France l'engagement total de la France
pour cette période triénale s'élvera
donc à
16,8 milliards
d'euros cet
engagement bien sûr est un engagement
qui repose sur la solidarité mais pas
seulement sur la solidarité également
sur
l'exigence premier principe c'est le
principe de solidarité la France a
toujours été un moteur dans l'histoire
de l'Europe ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative réaffirme notre engagement
à mettre en œuvre la solidarité
européenne mais dans cette affaire nous
ne sommes pas seuls les Européens sont
rejoints d'une certaine manière par un
soutien qui a été affirmé de manière
très solennelle par la Corée du Sud par
le Canada par les États-Unis et par le
Royaume-Uni qui bien sûr ne font pas
partie de la zone euro et qui ont
manifesté dès le 3 mai au côté de la
France leur soutien au plan en faveur de
la
Grèce outre l'aide financière consentie
par les membres de la zone euro ces pays
se sont engagés à favoriser l'octroit
rapide par le Fond Monétaire
International du soutien financier
exceptionnel à la Grèce c'est un signal
fort qui est est adressé au marché par
quatre États membres du G20 dont en
particulier la Corée du Sud et le Canada
qui sont actuellement en présidence
respective G7 G20 je vous indique au
passage que le conseil d'administration
du Fond Monétaire International se
tiendra dimanche à
Washington outre d'autres pays
importants pour le rôle qu'il joue au
sein du G20 le secteur financier c'est
également associé à notre effort hier à
l'occasion du Haut Comité de place les
banques françaises se sont engagées à
maintenir leur exposition sur la Grèce
leurs homologues allemandes s'étaient
engagé dans le même sens vis-à-vis de
Wolfgang chableu le ministre des
Finances allemand et le soutien toute à
la fois du secteur financier allemand et
du secteur financier français St autant
de gares complémentaires d'une
solidarité à l'égard de la Grèce mais la
solidarité n'exclut pas bien entendu la
vigilance et nous le devons au
contribuable français ce principe de
fermeté nous allons l'exercer à l'égard
d'un plan de redressement prévu par le
gouvernement grec et approuvé par le
Parlement grec depuis ce soir c'est un
plan rigoureux c'est un plan ambitieux
c'est un plan nécessaire ce sont les
trois term utilisés par Monsieur Papa
andreéou le Premier ministre grec il
prévoit notamment des hausses d'impôts
hausse de la TVA de de points
supplémentaires portant ainsi la TVA à
23 % augmentation des droits d'accise
sur l'alcool le t et les produits
pétroliers mais aussi des réductions de
dépenses publiques par la suppression
des 13e et 14e mois dans la fonction
publique et réforme en profondeur du
système de retraite avec un allongement
de la durée des cotisations le programme
prévoit également des mesures plus
structurelles pour rétablir la
compétitivité de l'économie grecque
modernisation de l'administration
publique administration de la
amélioration de la
concurrence ces mesures sont certes
ambitieuses difficile rigoureuse mais
impérative la Grèce doit être en mesure
de revenir sur des marchés à des
conditions raisonnabl et ce pour
rassurer non seulement les marchés les
institutions financières mais également
ses partenaires je vous rappelle que tel
qu'il est configuré le programme actuel
Fond Monétaire International commission
préserve intégralement la Grèce pendant
une période de 18 mois puisqu'il la met
littéralement à l'écart du besoin de se
financer ou de se refinancer sur les
marchés pendant toute cette période je
soutiens donc naturellement les mesures
difficiles pris par le gouvernement grec
et je ne doute pas un seul instant de sa
détermination à remettre son économie
sur les rails la France comme le reste
des États membres de la zone euro sera
très attentive à la mise en œuvre des
engagements de la Grèce c'est la
condition de la crédibilité du plan de
soutien et du retour de la confiance
cette confiance est nécessaire pour que
le calme revien viennent sur les marchés
les mouvements de ces derniers jours
révèlent des mouvements irrationnels qui
ne reflètent pas les fondamentaux
économiques d'un certain nombre de pays
visés par ces mouvements je l'ai dit et
je le répète les comparaisons entre un
certain nombre de ces pays et la Grèce
sont hors de
propos par ailleurs le versement de
chacune des tranches de ce financement
exceptionnel sera conditionné au respect
du programme convenu et ce contrôle
s'effectuera tous les 3 mois mois nous
pensons également qu'il est souhaitable
que les conditions qui sont faites à la
Grèce soient similaires à celles
pratiquées par le Fond monétaire
internationale en général et qui visent
à encourager un retour le plus rapide
possible à des financements de marché
cette exigence sera également la vôtre
puisque je m'engage ainsi que mon
collègue françois Barouin à venir vous
présenter tous les trimestres l'état de
la mise en œuvre des engagements de la
Grèce au programme de soutien nous nous
y sommes également solennellement
engagés vis-à-vis de la Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous l'avez vu nous sommes
déterminés à avancer mais si l'urgence
aujourd'hui est de résoudre la crise
grec il faut également que nous soyons
prêt sur le moyen et sur le long terme à
tirer toutes les conclusions afin
d'éviter la survenance de nouvelles
crises la gouvernance économique
européenne a fait l'objet de nombreuses
questions lors de nos débats à
l'Assemblée je suis certaine que nous en
reparlerons la question de la
coordination de nos politiques
économiques l'amélioration de la
fiabilité de nos statistiques ou la mise
en place de moyens adaptés de réponse en
cas de difficultés économiques et
financières de la zone euro sont à
l'étude aussi bien au niveau de la
Commission européenne que du groupe de
travail mise en place par le Conseil
européen sous l'autorité du président
Van rompoy et auquel le président de la
République m'a demandé de participer par
ailleurs la question de la gouvernance
de la zone euro sera bien sûr à l'ordre
du jour du Conseil européen
extraordinaire convoqué demain en forme
de sommet de l'Eurogroupe au niveau des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement enfin
autre chapitre celui de la régulation
financière sur lequel nous devons
poursuivre amplifier et accélérer nos
efforts la crise grecque a démontré que
nous devions continuer à lutter contre
les dysfonctionnements criants des
marchés des dérivés de crédit
c'est-à-dire les CDs et que nous devions
impérativement mettre en vigueur puisque
sa date d'application est le 7 juin le
règlement relatif aux agences de
notation et envisager dans un cadre
national un durcissement d'un certain
nombre des mesures voilà monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs les remarqu que je voulais
vous présenter avant de laisser la
parole à mon collègue françois Barouin
qui vous présentera le détail de ce
projet de loi de finance
rectificative je vous remercie madame la
ministre et je donne la parole à
Monsieur françois Barouin ministre du
budget des comptes publics et de la
réforme de l'État vous avez la parole
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Romanie
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général du budget mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs le projet de loi de finan
rectificative que je vous présente avec
Christine Lagarde qui vient d'évoquer
les grandes lignes l'esprit la
philosophie et les conditions de la
solidarité européenne à l'égard de la
Grèce nous amène à nous retrouver
quelques jours après le débat qui a
animé l'Assemblée nationale et qui a
permis de mettre en lumière comme je
l'imagine devant la Haute Assemblée les
enjeux les objectifs le calendrier la
méthode retenue et les conditions
d'avancement de ce plan le 23 avril
dernier la Grèce a donc fait
officiellement appel à l'aide européenne
face à la gravité de sa situation
financière les ministres de l'économie
de la zone euro ont adopté dimanche
dernier un accord prévoyant le
déclenchement d'un plan d'aide à la
Grèce sur 3 ans pour autant et j'insiste
sur ce point comme Christine l'a fait il
y a quelques instants cette aide n'est
en aucune manière un blanc sein accordé
à la Grèce la solidarité et la confiance
n'exclut pas l'exigence et le contrôle
cette aide est donc soumise à la mise en
œuvre effective d'un programme
d'assainissement des comptes publics sur
lequel le gouvernement grec s'est engagé
ce sont des mesures courageuses
contraignantes difficiles douloureuses
indiscutablement pour la population
grecque nous le voyons mais gardons à
l'esprit que derrière ce dispositif
c'est tout un peuple qui va devoir subir
ce plan d'austérité drastique mais ces
mesures sont nécessaires elles sont
indispensables nous souhaitons donner à
la France les outils et les moyens
budgétaires lui permettant de tenir
rapidement les engagements qu'elle a
pris au niveau européen comme cela a été
rappelé dans l'accord européen intervenu
dimanche la Grèce doit refinancer une
partie de sa dette dès le 19 mai et pour
que le dispositif de soutien soit
effectif avant cette date le
gouvernement souhaite que le projet de
loi de finance rectificatif puisse être
adopté rapidement dans ces circonstances
exceptionnelles la France se doit en
effet d'être en mesure de respecter ses
engagement européen et je vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs pour
la célérité avec laquelle ce texte a été
inscrit en séance publique je vous
précise enfin que ce projet de loi a été
amendé par le gouvernement devant
l'Assemblée nationale nous l'avons
évoqué devant votre commission des
finances afin de prévoir les conditions
d'un prêt de la France sur 3 ans au lieu
d'un an prévu initialement et à
réintégrer dans le texte de loi le
décret d'avance transmis à votre
assemblée le 19 avril dernier ce qui
semble être un bon élément de fluidité
de entre l'exécutif et le législatif et
ça permet d'accéder aussi à une demande
bien légitime de votre commission des
finances n permettra aussi d'intégrer
dans le projet de loi le financement les
dépenses urgentes pour lesquelles nous
avions préparé ce décret d'avance à
savoir l'aide pour Haïti et les suites
de la tempête xintia quelques mots
complémentaires de ce qu'a évoqué ma
collègue ministre de l'Économie
concernant
d'abord le dispositif prévu pour l'aide
à la Grèce c'est en fait une ouverture
d'un total de 16 milillards 800 millions
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement sur
un programme qui est créé à cet effet
ces 16 milillards 8 correspondent à
l'engagement de la France sur 3 ans
conformément au plan d'aide européen à
la Grèce que chacun connaît bien
désormais l'origine de ce montant est
est la suivante les 16 millards 800
millions d'euros représentent
l'engagement maximum de la France sur
les 80 milliards d'euros d'aide
européenne annoncé pour les 3 ans le
niveau de participation de chaque État
membre là aussi euh ce point est bien
connu car il a été souligné avec bonheur
et et avec répétition pour bien
comprendre les raisons pour lesquelles
nous sommes arrivés à ce chiffre c'est
le prorata de la position française et
c'est à hauteur de 21 % lié à la
souscription de la banque centrale
nationale au capital de la Banque
centrale européenne le Fond Monétaire
International prêterait quant à lui à la
Grèce après approbation probable dans la
semaine comme ça a été évoqué par
Christine avec le calendrier précis 30
milliards d'euros en vertu de l'accord
qui est conclu entre l'Union européenne
et la Grèce sur ces 16 milillards 800
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement sur 3 ans le montant des
crédits de paiement ouverts en France
pour la première année soit jusqu'à la
fin de 2010 s'élève à 3 millard900
millions en 2011-22 voire début 2013 si
le plan se prolonge effectivement sur 3
années à partir d'aujourd'hui des
crédits de paiement supplémentaires
pourront être ouverts si nécessaire nous
reviendrons selon un rendez-vous
trimestriel si euh vous êtes en accord
avec cette proposition pour vous tenir
informé de l'évolution naturellement de
l'application des mesures en Grèce et
l'évolution des demandes et des besoins
de soutien proposés par la France ou
demandé à la France dans ce cas de
figure je tiens à préciser que ces
ouvertures de crédit n'ont pas d'impact
sur le déficit public de la France car
il s'agit d'une opération financière il
s'agit d'un prêt c'est une dépense non
définitive pour le budget de l'État quel
que soit le montant décaissé au titre
des prêts à la Grèce la prévision du
déficit public pour 2010 reste donc
inchangé par rapport au montant que nous
avons notifié à la Commission européenne
à savoir 8 points de PIB en revanche
l'accroissement du déficit budgétaire
pour 2010 est de 3 milliards par rapport
au chiffre de la loi de finance
rectificative relative aux
investissements d'avenir et même si le
décaissement de ces crédits n'est pas à
ce stade certain et qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une dépense définitive le déficit
budgétaire doit refléter la sincérité de
l'ensemble des crédits budgétaires qui
sont autorisés c'est la raison pour
laquelle le déficit budgétaire 2010
s'élèvera dans le projet de loi de
finance rectificative à 150 2 milliards
d'euros comme vous pouvez le constater
toutefois mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs cette dégradation n'est que de
3 milliards et non de 3 milillard 9 la
raison en est simple c'est que
l'ouverture des 3 milliards 9 d'euros de
crédit de paiement est en partie
compensée par une réévaluation qui a
déjà été elle-même signalée le 8 avril
dernier à Bruxelles de la hausse des
recettes de TVA pour 900 millions ces
ouvertures de crédit pour 2010 n'ont pas
non plus d'impact sur la charge de la
dette et n'implique pas de modifier en
conséquence le programme d'émission de
la dette française ni pour la dette
dette à moyen long terme ni pour la
dette à court terme ce programme
d'émission reste donc semblable à celui
qui a été présenté lors du précédent
collectif j'ajouterai quelques mots
comme je l'ai dit en en introduction à
propos des ouvertures et des alumations
de crédit salué par le président de la
commission des finances à juste titre
introduit dans ce projet de loi par
l'intégration du décret d'avance qui
vous avait été présenté le 19 avril nous
avions en effet envoyer aux commissions
des finances des deux assemblées un
projet de décret d'avance qui était
destiné à ouvrir des crédits pour faire
face à l'aide d'urgence à la
reconstruction d'Haïti à la réparation
d'un certain nombre de dégâts causés par
la tempête xintia le dépôt du projet de
loi de finance rectificative le 21 avril
dernier et la diligence dont on su faire
preuve il faut leur rendre hommage les
deux assemblées dans son insccription à
l'ordre du jour rendre possible le
passage par la voie législative plutôt
que par la voie du décret d'avance ce
qui et je l'évoquais est à la fois plus
simple plus fluide et d'une certaine
manière aussi beaucoup plus respectueuse
pour les uns et pour les autres afin de
réaliser ses ouvertures je rappellerai
que brièvement si vous me le permettez
la teneur de ces mesures puisque le
décret d'avance est déjà connu de tous
il s'agit d'une part d'ouvrir 45
millions d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et 35 millions en crédit de
paiement pour le financement des
opérations d'urgence en faveur d'Haïti
et je vous rappelle que ce céisme a
causé la mort de plus de 200000
personnes mais que la France a pris des
engagements qu'elle les tiendra c'est
une certaine idée de la position
française en matière de solidarité
internationale lors de catastrophes
naturelles d'autre part il s'agit
d'ouvrir 60 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 40 millions
en crédit de paiement pour faire face là
à la tempête xintia qui a frappé nos
côtes c'est une aide exceptionnelle
apportter aux collectivités locales et
aux agriculteurs pour les dégâts non
assurables qu'ils ont subis c'est aussi
l'indemnisation des collectivités
territorial j'avais abordé ce point à
l'occasion d'une question d'actualité il
y a quelques semaines par exemple pour
aider les
collectivités dans la gestion des biens
qui ne sont pas assurables la voirée
communale départementale les réseaux
d'assainissement d'eau potable les
stations d'puration les relevages des
EAU l'ensemble de ces ouvertures sur la
partie technique est engagé par des
annulations de même montant portant sur
des crédits mis en réserve sur les
programmes relevant des différents
ministères il n'y a donc pas là non plus
d'impact sur le déficit budgétaire je
conclurai brièvement nous sommes et
chacun mesure chaque jour un peu plus
confrontés aujourd'hui à des enjeux
décisifs et nous pouvons et nous le
savons pouvoir compter sur votre esprit
de responsabilité pour que les débats se
concentrent naturellement sur l'objet du
projet de loi amendé par le gouvernement
afin de permettre cette adoption dans
les plus brevs délin pour permettre à la
France d'être au rendez-vous des
engagements qui ont été pris à l'échelle
européenne dans le cadre de cette
solidarité vis-à-vis d'un pays ami et
qui entraîne avec lui aussi la défense
de notre monnaie
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Marini rapporteur général de la
commission des
finances
Madame le Ministre de l'économie
monsieur le ministre du Budget mes chers
collègues nous sommes saisis du 2 projet
de loi de finan rectificative de l'année
2010 et son dispositif ayant été décrit
très précisément par les ministres qui
m'ont précédé à cette
tribune je n'y reviendrai pas dans le
détail je soulignerai comme ils l'ont
fait que le sol de dit mastrichien n'est
pas impacté par l'aide à la Grèce car il
s'agit d'opération
financière et que d'autre part le solde
budgétaire est lui aggravé de 3
milliards
d'euros ce qui cependant ne nécessite
pas d'accroître notre programme
d'emprunt relevons à ce stade que les
recettes de trésorerie qui ont pu être
mobilisé de même que la
réévaluation du produit de la TVA sont
en revanche des données budgétaires qui
si elles n'étit pas consacré à cette
opération auraient été de nature à
améliorer le solde de notre fin
d'exercice et donc de réduire le
programme
d'endettement je suis heureux que le
gouvernement ait incorporé les
dispositions du décret d'avance et en
particulier
sans une disposition que nous avions
critiqué donc le gouvernement et qui ne
portait que sur 600000 € mais ceci
montre que le gouvernement a
écouté l'avis de la commission des
finances et qu'il en a tenu
compte sur le fond des
choses chacun sait que la situation très
critique de la Grèce provient de
l'incertitude des chiffres de ces
finances publiques et qu'à trois
reprises en 2004 en 2008 en 2009 il a
été nécessaire de les redresser pour les
rendre conforme à la réalité il est bon
de rappeler aussi que nos FAM grec ont
bénéficié d'une belle période de
croissance notamment financé par les
fonds structurels
européens je crois que parmi les
questions posées il y aura celle d'une
évaluation de l'efficacité des
politiques structurelles ainsi
conduites il est bien compréhensible que
les milieux financiers est pris peur à
propos de l'emballement des finan
gre car dès lors que le taux de
croissance de ce pays
baissait la soutenabilité de sa dette
publique diminuait et on ne cessait de
s'écarter de ce que nous appelons le
solld de stabilisant c'est-à-dire celui
qui évite
l'accroissement et l'accroissement d
raisonnable de la dette
publique saurit donc être surpris des
jugements portés par les analystes et en
particulier par les agences de notation
sur la situation de la Grèce et sur la
soutenabilité dans le moyen long terme
de ces finances
publiques ce qui à l'inverse a surpris
beaucoup d'entre nous c'est la
communication de ces mêmes agences et il
SAG agit là de l'un des aspects dans
l'enchaînement de la crise sur lesquels
il nous faudra revenir au niveau
international et au niveau national au
titre de la
régulation il est clair que nous avons
le devoir l'impérieux devoir de sortir
de l'impasse une union
monétaire qui n'a pas prévu qui n'avait
pas prévu de mécanism de résolution des
crises de mécanisme de traitement des
chocs
asymétriques une union
monétaire dont le système de décision
met des mois à faire face à des
situations
d'urgence tout ceci bien entendu nous
conduit à quelques
réflex la situation dramatique de la
Grèce si nous savons en tirer toutes les
conséquences peut tout à fait j'en ai la
conviction être un facteur de progrès
pour l'Union européenne et plus
particulièrement pour la zone
euro nous pouvons souhaiter que
l'événement tragique que vit la
population grecque
qui va devoir se soumettre à des mesures
dures nous pouvons souhaiter que cet
événement
tragique soit réellement le point de
départ d'une nouvelle gouvernance de la
zone
euro nous avons en outre constaté c'est
une bonne chose madame la ministre que
l'intervention du Fond Monétaire
International n'est plus un
tabou l'Union
européenne les pays de la zone euro
figurent parmi les premiers
contributeurs au Fond Monétaire
International il serait bien
paradoxal que l'on écarte le Fond
Monétaire International qui a toute la
technicité le professionnalisme
nécessaire pour accompagner la
restructuration financière d'un pays
qu'on l' écarte
de du financement de cette
restructuration
indispensable le plan dont nous avons
pris connaissance le plan de soutien
dont nous avons pris connaissance est du
point de vue de la commission des
finances d'une
ampleur tout à fait de nature à éviter
la
contagion et le gouvernement a très bien
fait d'amender le texte à l'Assemblée
nationale pour englober la totalité des
engagements sur les 3 années du plan ce
plan est certes exig quant aux
contrepartis aux conditionnalités qui
sont imposé à la Grèce il ne peut en
aller autrement sinon on ne ferait
qu'encourager laaléa morale et
inciter tous les autres États qui
connaissent et c'est bien naturel dans
cette période de sortie de crise des
problèmes de rareté de l'argent public à
laisser filer leur déficit et leur
dettes
mais j'y reviens car c'est l'essentiel
la question de la gouvernance de la
monnaie unique est enfin sur la
table il n'est plus possible
d'entretenir la fiction sur laquelle
nous avons vécu la fiction selon
laquelle les 27 membres de l'Union
européenne auraient vocation à être à
court terme dans l'euro je crois que
c'est une idée qu'il faut éloigner de
nos pensé du moins immédiate il est
également il est surtout indispensable
de renforcer
l'Eurogroupe d'en faire un vrai organe
institutionnel de l'Union européenne de
manière à ce que la surveillance
mutuelle que doivent exercer les États
de la zone euro les uns sur les autres
s'appuie sur des procédures sur des
méthodes sur un vrai secrétariat sur des
modes d'intervention
adéquates cette gouvernance renforcée
est une absolue nécessité il en est une
autre c'est celle d'améliorer les moyens
de connaissance et d'appréciation des
comptes publics et parmi les
propositions de notre commission des
finances figure celle de mettre en place
un nouvel organe de l'Union qui serait
est une autorité européenne des comptes
publics il n'est pas compréhensible
qu'en
2010 les États ne s'astreignent pas à
une méthodologie de leur compte qui soit
aussi exigeante que celle des grandes
entreprises il y a une normalisation
comptable internationale pour les
entreprises ayant recours au marché les
États de la zone euro qui ont recours au
marché doivent être dotés de comptes
incontestables dont la méthodologie
soit fixé collectivement par un organe
de l'Union
et nous serions heureux que l'on veuille
bien réfléchir à ce progrès
indispensable de la construction
communautaire car ce serait un progrès à
la fois en terme de confiance de tous
ceux qui nous regardent confiance des
marchés en particulier ce serait un
excellent signal ce serait aussi le gage
de la durée de
l'euro voilà quelques
considérations qui bien sûr non' de
valeur non de sens que si la zone euro
est en mesure de se doter d'une
politique économique et c'est tout le
sujet de la gouvernance économique qui
est à nouveau présent dans notre débat
c'est la question des objectifs a
assigné à la Banque centrale européenne
qui devra de même être posé
c'est en germe la question de
l'harmonisation fiscale entre les États
de la zone euro c'est la question de la
coordination des politiques budgétaires
et à cet égard la France par les
positions qu'elle prend par les
attitudes qu'elle adopte par les
politiques qu'elle suit doit assurément
être exemp exlaire nous ne pouvons
concevoir notre pays
qu'exemplaire il ne sert à rien d'avoir
raison sur les principes si l'on n'est
pas convainquant dans les faits et nos
prises de position par exemple en faveur
d'un gouvernement économique de la zone
euro serait encore plus forte si notre
politique budgétaire était encore plus
vertueuse madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre pour être crédible je le répète
il faut être exemplaire et à cet égard
l'exemplarité c'est le chemin de
convergence c'est le
respect dans la lettre et dans l'esprit
du programme de stabilité
2010-203 transmis à la Commission
européenne en janvier dernier au
demurant et dans l'avenir nous pouvons
souhaiter qu'un tel programme soit
soumis au Parlement soit voté par le
Parlement comme certains états le
pratiquent des gà et la crise c'est l'un
de ses mérites elle contraint les
gouvernements à la cohérence première
étape du chemin vers la
convergence
aujourd'hui il n'est plus
concevable
d'observer un écart entre le langage
interne et le langage
externe ce serait un risque que l'on ne
pourrait plus imaginer de prendre et
voilà ce qui qui est nouveau le double
langage n'est plus possible mes chers
collègues réjouissons-nous de cela car
c'est un vrai progrès de la démocratie
ce à quoi l'on s'engage il faut le faire
et s'y tenir avec persévérance et quoi
qu'il en
coûte les décisions de notre
gouvernement ne saurait me
semble-t-il être
efficace dans l'opinion quen s'appuyant
sur cette cohérence sur cette constance
et naturellement sur l'appui des
assemblées parlementairire alors je
terminerai par ce que
j'appellerai la feuille de route de la
crédibilité et plusieurs étapes
cruciales nous attendent pour les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois la conférence sur le sur les
finances publiques sur le déficit public
nous est annoncé pour la fin du mois de
mai et permettra au président de la
République de prendre acte des travaux
des groupe dont il a suscité la création
et de définir des lignes
directrices le 2
juin
seront notifiés à la Commission les
complément qu'elle nous a demandé
c'est-à-dire les explications qu'appelle
notre programme de stabilité et de
croissance 2010
2013 puis nous nous retrouverons très
vite dans nos hémicycles pour le débat
d'orientation budgétaire et celui-ci
pour 2011 sera particulièrement crucial
j'ai pris connaissance comme vous mes
chers collègues et j'ai pris
connaissance
avec
vraiment une appréciation très positive
de l'initiative qui a été prise
aujourd'hui par le Premier ministre
François Fillon de réunir son
gouvernement et de tracer le cap pour la
préparation budgétaire de l'année
2011 commission des finances du Sénat ne
peut que vous encourager madame monsieur
le ministre dans cette voie
et bien sûr dire au Premier ministre
combien cette initiative est
indispensable et
salutaire bien sûr d'autres étapes nous
attendre et toujours dans la même
période de temps l'annonce des principes
de la réforme des retraite il est clair
que cette réforme qui est essentielle
sur le plan
macro-économique qui est essentielle sur
le plan social
et pour sécuriser nos
compatriotes cette réforme
c'est un sujet tout à fait essentiel
c'est un sujet absolument stratégique et
de cette annonce de
l'annonce des des orientations qui
devraient intervenir cet été vont
dépendre beaucoup beaucoup de choses il
reste le débat sur les normes sur les
règles que nous pouvons nous proposer et
qu'il nous faudra
suivre le débat est ouvert
et les travaux du groupe présidé par
Michel Cansu sont très stimulants mais
je voudrais pour ma part proposer un
principe très simple qui ne nécessite
aucune connaissance économétrique
particulière il s'agirait tout
simplement de réserver
au lois de finances et au lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale toute
décision ayant un impact ou un impact
potentiel sur le solde des finances
publiques le jour où l'on fera ça et je
me permet de dire dans le langage actuel
que c'est un marqueur le jour où l'on
fera cela et bien on pourra se persuader
que l'on est vraiment avec toute la
volonté nécessaire sur le chemin de la
gence et que l'on donne et que l'on se
donne les moyens de mettre en œuvre une
vraie politique du
solde alors mes chers
collègues les circonstances sont
difficiles les choses ont vraiment
changé ces derniers jours les attitudes
vont devoir changer mais si nous voulons
que qu'au sein de l'opinion publique les
efforts que nous faisons soient
accompagnés nous n devons la vérité nous
devons
l'équité nous devons être capable de
montrer que tout ce qui est fait tous
les efforts qui sont demandés le sont
pour sauvegarder notre
souveraineté pour sauvegarder notre
liberté de décision si on laisse filer
les choses il est clair que la part des
ressources publiques que l'on consacrera
à rembourser des emprunts fera obstacle
à toute réelle liberté ou en tout cas
toute marche de manœuvre suffisante de
la part des pouvoirs publics or de
liberté de liberté d'allocation des
moyens publics nous avons grand besoin
merci de votre
attention je remercie monsieur le
rapporteur général la parole est à
Monsieur Jean uis président de la
commission des
finances
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
de l'économie monsieur le ministre du
Budget mes chers
collègues ce deuxème collectif
budgétaire de l'année intervient dans un
contexte de triple
sauvetage sauvetage de notre partenaire
grec qui n'est plus aujourd'hui en
capacité de trouver sur les marchés la
ressource qu'il doit
emprunter sauvetage de la zone euro de
l'Un union monétaire qui à force de
tergiversation a frôé le collapsus et
doit se ressaisir
d'urgence sauvetage enfin des créances
détenues par les banques parmi
lesquelles les banques françaises figure
en bon rang la France depuis le début de
cette crise a joué pleinement son rôle
au nom du devoir de solidarité au nom de
la haute idée qu'elle se fait de
l'Europe comme destin partagé entre
toutes les nations qui la composent elle
a d'emblé tracé les grandes ligne d'un
plan d'action qui a fini par s'imposer à
tous je suis reconnaissant au
gouvernement de son action et l'en
félicite sans aucun suspens je crois
pouvoir dire que nous voterons pour la
plupart sur ces bancs un projet de loi
de finance rectificative dont finalement
la principale qualité et de nous révéler
à quel point nous sommes aujourd'hui le
dos au mur contraint de réagir et
d'abandonner les faux semblants qui nous
ont collectivement conduit à l'épisode
désastreux que nous venons de vivre car
au fond comme vient de le rappeler avec
Briot le rapporteur général tous ces
événements qui se traduisent par la mise
sous protectorat de la Grèce par la
dégringolade de l'euro par un risque pas
encore complètement écarté de
désintégration de la monnaie unique tout
cela n'était-il pas éminemment
prévisible nos partenaires Grecs n'ont
pas su abandonner des pratiques
comptables et budgétaires regrettable
qui les ont conduit à l'impasse actuel
certes mais le problème n'est-il pas
plus profond et comme inscrit dans la
genèse de la monnaie unique car ce que
révèle la crise dramatique que nous
traversons ce sont je le pense les
graves défauts les graves fragilités les
grave lacunes de la gouvernance de la
zone euro qu'il me soit permis d'évoquer
ici mes souvenirs de ministre des
Finances ayant participé à l'élaboration
du pacte de stabilité et de croissance à
Dublin à l'automne
1996 la monnaie unique était le
complément indispensable
du marché unique la démonstration en
était faite chaque mois au début des
années 90 lorsque survenaient les
dévaluations compétitives qui ruinaient
la croissance et détruisaient
massivement des emplois il fallait une
monnaie unique et nous avons pris à
cette époque le risque de faire naître
une monnaie pour la première fois dans
le monde une monnaie orpheline d'État
pour palier l'absence de pouvoir
politique pour palier le déficit de
gouvernance économique nous avons dû
concevoir un règlement de copropriété de
l'euro gage de viabilité et de
crédibilité du système malheureusement
les transgressions se sont
multipliées je crois même que certains
états peut-être même la France se sont
parfois laissés aller à des déficits
excessifs car il n'encourrait pas la
sanction monétaire il n'y avait pas le
risque de dévaluation nous savions
d'emblé les difficultés que sa mise en
œuvre finirait t tout tard par engendrer
parce que les économies qui cohabit au
sein de la zone euro sont très
hétérogènes et ne convergent pas
spontanément parce que les mécanismes de
surveillance et de contraintte que
prévoit le pacte de stabilité sont sans
doute insuffisants mais aussi lacunaire
pour ne pas dire
défaillant convenons au surplu que le
juge politique car la décision finale
était politique que le juge politique a
du mal à se montrer rigoureux la crise
grecque n'a été que le révélateur d'un
vice et nous ne pouvions pas ignorer ce
qui finirait par arriver après le
rapporteur général je voudrais à mon
tour souligner l'ardente nécessité
d'améliorer la gouvernance de
l'Eurogroupe
cette institution doit mettre en place
des mécanismes de surveillance mutuelle
et de sanction permettant d'entraver
l'apparition des crises bien plus en
amont qu'elle ne le fait aujourd'hui
j'espère que cette crise va constituer
l'électrochoc salutaire dont nous avions
besoin il existe une cour des comptes
européennes dont le champ de compétence
s'arrête aux instances de l'Union et aux
organismes recevant des fonds
communautaires ne pourrait-on concevoir
une structure supranationale d'audit et
d'évaluation des comptes de l'ensemble
des collectivités public membres de
l'Europe ne pourrait-on imaginer des
audits croisés réalisés par les Cours
des comptes des différents États-membres
dans le cadre de cette surveillance
mutuelle évoquée par Philippe Marini
dans le rapport de la commission et
qu'il a rappelé il y a un instant à
cette tribune notre audition des
représentants d'Eurostat il y a un mois
nous a convaincus de la nécessité
d'instituer une autorité européenne des
comptes publics indépendantes et
disposant de moyens humains et matériels
conséquent le contrôle portant sur la
sincérité des comptes transmis par les
États-membres ne peut pas continuer de
reposer sur une vingtaine de
collaborateurs dont la capacité
d'expertise et de réaction est
nécessairement limitée un enseignement
majeur de la crise tient enfin au de
devoir
d'exemplarité de la France qui doit
renvoyer à ses partenaires qui doit
renvoyer aux opinions publiques au
marché financiers l'image d'un acteur
fiable résolument engagé dans la voie du
redressement de ses finances publiques
sans faux semblant et sans double
langage nous avons fait parvenir à
Bruxelles un programme de stabilité par
lequel nous avons annoncé notre volonté
de revenir au respect des critères
mastrichiens en 2013 comme la commission
nous l'avait demandé ce document
convenons-en madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre ce document repose sur des
hypothèses optimistes
oseraiis-je dire peut-être trop
optimiste si nous voulons aller jusqu'au
bout de la transparence si nous voulons
assurer notre crédibilité sans
arrière-pensé hors de tout
artifice alors oui il faudra qu'à
l'avenir les programmes de stabilité
soit acté par le Parlement comme cela se
fait chez nombre de nos partenaires et
qu'il y ait une parfaite cohérence entre
les lois de finances et ce programme de
stabilité
budgétaire des efforts que nous devrons
collectivement fournir mérit ce débat
public face au défi considéraable que
nous avons à relever nos compatriotes
ont besoin d'un langage de vérité
ils ont assez de maturité pour
l'entendre nous le leur devons encore
faut-il faire preuve de pédagogie pour
leur expliquer les enjeux et justifier
les choix qui seront faits oserais-je
dire que ce qui est anxiogène pour les
Français c'est un certain discours
convenu qui ne donne pas le sentiment
que l'on fait la vérité sur notre
situation au fond la crise grecque doit
être profitable pour l'Europe
elle nous offre une belle panoplie
d'instruments pédagogiques je vous
demande madame la ministre monsieur le
ministre d'en faire bon usage et de
permettre ainsi à l'Union européenne de
franchir une étape qualitative décisive
vous me permettraz à ce sujet pour
conclure d'exprimer un reproche et un
vœux un reproche est-ce vraiment faire
preuve de pédagogie et de volonté de
transparence que de dire madamees
monsieurs les ministres que le coût du
prêt à la gr sera sans effet sur la
trésorerie de l'État certes nous ne
devrions pas avoir à recourir à des
emprunts supplémentaires cette année
pour couvrir le besoin de financement
induit par la somme que nous allons
verser à la Grèce mais enfin ces 3
milliards 900 millions d'euros que nous
allons devoir débourser et bien ces 3
milliards 900 millions c'est autant qui
n'iront pas au remboursement de notre
dette c'est autant d'allègement du
recours à l'emprunt dont nous ne
pourrons bénéficier alors je fais un vu
que nous disions enfin aux français où
nous en sommes exactement ce pays
connaît des déséquilibres colossaux qui
menace gravement sa
compétitivité dans un processus que je
n'hésite pas à qualifier de mortifère
notre matière taxable au premier chef
notre industrie s'enfuit vers des
destinations plus
hospitalières il ne suffit pas de
contrôler la progression des dépenses
publiques il faut les réduire lesquelles
dans quelle proportion c'est maintenant
que nous devons le dire le décider et le
faire le premier ministre a déclaré
aujourd'hui que les dépenses 2011
devront en valeur rester stablebl par
rapport à 2010 c'est une excellente
orientation mais je de mes chers
collègues que cela suffise les
normes que sans doute nous allons
adopter les normes en matière de déficit
public sont vaines s'il n'y a pas une
volonté politique et puis s'agissant des
normes madames monsieurs les
ministres vos collègues du gouvernement
viennent chaque semaine devant le Sénat
devant l'Assemblée nationale avec des
projets de loi qui instittuent de
nouvelles normes qui toutes aboutissent
à des suppléments de dépenses publiques
cette attitude est devenue insupportable
j'ose espérer que la loi sur
l'agriculture ne va pas comporter de
nouvelles normes et dictant la
composition des menus devant comporter
telle proportion de produits supposés
biologiques
ou bien les produits alimentaires sont
sains et qu'on laisse les gestionnaires
des cantines publiques fixer eux-mêm les
menus il y a un changement d'attitude
gouvernementale et parlementaire nous
avons à faire face à une situation
financière sans précédent et donc nous
devons modifier notre attitude
accueillir autrement les projets de loi
et de grâce cesser de légiférer sur des
sujets qui quelquefois ont sans doute un
impact médiatique ble mais qui sont
totalement en dehors des enjeux majeurs
que nous avons à assumer
l'échéance de la prochaine loi de
finance sera de ce point de vue décisive
soyons prêts à y répondre sous la double
exigence de rétablir la
compétitivité et de cela nous parlerons
encore madamees monsieurs les ministres
il y a dans notre fiscalité des
dispositions qui font que l'on taxe la
production alors quand on taxe la
production il faut pas s'étonner que la
production aille hors du territoire
prospérer et on ne rétablira pas
l'équilibre des finance publique sans
retour de la compétitivité permettez-moi
de vous dire que ces réformesl ne
peuvent plus attendre naturellement
c'est un peu récurrent ce propos à cette
tribune mais le problème des
parlementaires dont je suis c'est que
vient un moment où nous demandons si
notre mission a un sens et si elle a une
utilité et si nous ne devenons pas
complice
d'un certain délitement de nos finances
publiques donc j'espère que le
rendez-vous prochain de la loi de
finances nous permettra d'être
conséquent et que nos décisions seront à
la hauteur de nos propos soyez assurés
que la commission des finances y prendra
toute sa part il s'agit pour nous de
démontrer que les démocraties sont
capables de faire face à des situations
de crise qu'elles sont suffisant lucide
est courageuse pour enclencher un plan
de redressement je vous remercie de
votre
attention je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est à notre collègue
Denis
Badr merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ce soir nous examinons
le soutien financier que la France va je
l'espère apporter rapidement à la
Grèce même si comme souvent en cas
d'incendie il aurait mieux valu que le
pompier interviennne plus tôt même si le
pompier peut se dire qu'on aurait pu
mobiliser des moyens mieux
adaptés il ne se pose pas de question il
commence par éteindre j'indique donc
immédiatement que le groupe de l'Union
centriste votera le texte qui nous est
soumis pour les grec comme pour nous il
faut que la Grèce puisse assurer les
échéances auxquelles elle sera
confrontée dans quelques jours et il est
urgent de restaurer la confiance des
marchés financiers l'incendie
circonscrit sinon totalement éteint il
restera beaucoup à dire et à faire à
propos de cette crise il restera des
responsabilités à clarifier des
enseignements à dégager des réformes à
élaborer pour faire tout de même de
cette crise une opportunité opportunité
pour la Grèce pour l'Euro et pour la
poursuite de la construction européenne
si la Grèce s'est laissée emporter par
la tourmente elle y a une responsabilité
la semaine dernière j'ai eu l'occasion
d'en parler avec des collègues grecs de
toute sensibilité ils en sont
parfaitement conscients et vivent
évidemment assez mal cette lourde
épreuve tout est maintenant sur la table
déficit trop longtemps masqué
approximation comptable non respect des
engagements du PACT de stabilité et de
croissance insuffisance d'adaptation
structurelle économie peu
concurrentielle ceci désormais explicité
est-il utile pour autant d'accabler nos
amis grecs peut-être mais alors à
condition que cela serve à quelque chose
et que celui qui n'a pas pêché jette la
première pierre or d'autres acteurs
assez nombreux portent une part de
responsabilité les gouvernements
nationaux ne se sont jamais montrés très
disposés à donner à Eurostat de réel
pouvoir d'investigation pas plus qu'à le
transformant en un instrument commun
indépendant et impartial d'analyse et de
référence la question doit se poser
désormais surtout lorsqu'on sait qu'un
rapport de la commission daté du mois de
janvier récapitulait les doutes exprimés
par Eurostat sur la grcee sans que cela
est alors réellement ému grand monde
bien sûr une réforme d'Eurostat
viendrait limite disons la créativité
comptable des états et bien tant pis il
est évidemment plus important de
prévenir les catastrophes madame la
ministre vous avez déjà analysé les
responsabilités des agences de notation
dégradant à chaud l'appréciation portée
sur la Grèce à une très mauvaise heure
puisque c'était à quelques minutes de la
clôture des marchés bien tardivement
alors que la crise avait pris toute son
ampleur et surtout en un moment o aucun
élément vraiment nouveau ne justifia une
nouvelle correction elles ont joué un
rôle de bout de feu pour le plus grand
profil des spéculateurs nous aurions
préféré les voir exercer leurs talents
en d'autres temps pour prédire la crise
de 2009 à ce sujet il faudra d'ailleurs
se poser la question de la notation des
états et de leur situation particulière
par rapport au marchés financiers y
sont-ils vraiment justiciables des mêmes
règles que les autres acteurs financiers
la situation des banques et leurs
responsabilités spécifique à l'origine
de tes difficultés ou pour concourir à
dénouer ce type de crise peuvent
également poser problème notre
commission des finances monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur général y
réfléchira certainement mais il me
semble bon que dès aujourd'hui elle soit
impliquée dans le sauvetage vous l'avez
dit je crois que c'est bien je passe aux
responsabilités plus collective des
États et des institutions européennes
dans cette crise il s'agit bien sûr de
marquer qu'une claire solidarité unit de
fait l'ensemble des membres de
l'Eurogroup il me semble donc
symboliquement fort que les 15
partenaires de la Grèce soient tous
solidairement mis à contribution au
prorat de leur part dans le capital de
la BCE quelle que soit leur situation du
moment la participation à l'Union
économique et monétaire implique des
droits et des devoir l'effort demandé à
Chypre à la Slovaquie ou au Portugal et
de fait relativement aussi lourd àortter
pour eux que celui consenti par la
France ou l'Allemagne il faut donc
saluer leur
engagement nous avons ici un parfait
exemple des solidarités de fête de
Robert Schuman soutenir la Grèce c'est
bien marquer une solidarité
incontournable c'est aussi l'intérêt
bien compris de tous d'enrayer une crise
dont le caractère potentiellement
compéagieux n'échappe à personne la
tourmente des dernières heures sur les
marchés le rappelle à nouveau derrière
la Grèce c'est en réalité l'euro qu'il
faut défendre contre les marchés ou
contre les spéculateurs décidé à
l'attaquer en ciblant les maillons
faibles j'en viens donc à notre monnaie
dont le président artui soulignait à
juste titre à l'instant qu'elle est
orpheline d'État prenons le dollar si
une crise intervient dans un des États
de l'Union l'État fédéral joue son rôle
tout naturellement qui dit banque
centrale indépendante ne dit pas du tout
alors absence d'État la Banque centrale
européenne elle fonctionne sans état
avec l'euro elle a protégé les membres
de l'Union économique et monétaire
depuis 2 ans face à la crise on ne le
dira jamais assez pour faire la
promotion de l'euro protecteur j'ai
plaisir à citer les autorités Slovaques
lorsqu'elle soulligent que si le fait
d'être dans l'euro a bien sûr aider leur
pays ce qui les a d'abord protégé c'est
l'effet des réformes structurelles
qu'elles ont dû mettre en œuvre pour se
qualifier pour la monnaie unique voici
un argumentaire vertueux qui ne
peut-être qui n'est peut-être pas
inutile de rappeler alors que l'euro est
dans la tourmente pour conclure
provisoirement sur l'euro il y a eu
évidemment à tout le moins manque de
coordination économique et carence de la
Commission en l'absence d'un état ou
d'un véritable pouvoir politique il fait
au minimum que chacun assume sa
responsabilité commission comprise ou
commission d'abord alors aujourd'hui
nous sommes autant du kit tout double
jamais en effet les risques de
désintégration n'ont été aussi réels
puisqu'on en vient à évoquer ouvertement
d'éventuelles sorties de l'Euro avec
gourmandis parfois trop souvent en les
banalisant or qui dit sortie de l'euro
dit négation du PACT de stabilité et de
croissance fin de la solidarité ruine de
la confiance voilà pour le kit
heureusement jamais non plus on aperçu
aussi clairement une réelle attente de
mesures radicales allant jusqu'à la
création d'un fond monétaire européen ou
visant des dispositions contraignantes
d'harmonisation des budgets on peut sans
doute appeler ce temps celui de la
volonté politique le conseil de vendredi
madame le ministre monsieur le ministre
vient à point j'espère que cette attente
ne sera pas déçue voilà pour le double
j'en vient à notre responsabilité
collective au sein de l'Union
l'insuffisance de coordination
économique s'est conjuguée avec une
surveillance trop lâche pire il faut
connaître que de mauvais exemples ont
été donnés par des états parmi les plus
grands je ne parle peut-être ni de la
France ni de l'Allemagne mais chacun
appréciera mais nous ne l'aurons pas la
nécessaire révision du fonctionnement
économique de l'Union ne peut se faire
que dans le sens d'un renforcement des
disciplines communes cela ne plaira pas
à tout le monde peut-être pas à la
France non plus d'ailleurs or il s'agit
bien d'attendre plus d'Europe à partir
du moment où nous sommes engagés sur la
voie de l'Union économique et monétaire
jeanartu le rappelit à l'instant il faut
aller de l'avant sauf à nous voir
exposer au retour chronique de telle
catastrophe madame le ministre vous avez
fort justement insisté sur le rôle actif
qu'a joué la France pour que soit dégagé
une solution et que celle-ci soit
vraiment européenne et vous aviez raison
de le faire je pense cependant qu'en le
qu'en le faisant il faut veiller à ne
pas stigmatiser l'attitude d'une
Allemagne qui pourrait par comparaison
être alors présentée comme moins
européenne le plan venit d'être adopté
par le Bundestag et c'est bien mais il
est clair que l'opinion dans le pays
reste assez réservée non pas tant parce
que les Allemands se voudraient moins
généreux ou moins solidaire mais parce
ce coutrerin tout ce qui touche à la
monnaie reste hypersensible il ne faut
jamais sous-estimer cette réalité les
Allemands ont de plus parfois le
sentiment d'avoir été floués ils
considèrent qu'ils ont offert leur
marque sur l'hôtel d'un euro dont on
leur avait affirmé qu'il serait stable
et garanti par des règles sérieuses mis
en œuvre avec rigueur une clause
rassurante de non assistance
expressément introduite dans le traité
de Maastricht avait même à l'époque
était largement médiatisé en Allemagne
enfin les Allemands apprécient vraiment
très peu d'être montrés du doigt alors
même qu'ils éprouv une réelle fierté
pour voir réaliser ces progrès de
compétitivité que tous leurs partenaires
européens auraient dû engager notamment
en matière de modération salariale ou
d'effort à l'exportation ils ont le
sentiment d'être un peu seul à ramer à
contrecourant dans une Europe dont le
problème dans la mondialisation est
précisément une perte générale de
compétitivité et là nous avons peu de
leçons à leur donner ne vaut-il pas
mieux donc assumer le tout sans réserve
et conjointement avec eux les décisions
prises comme les atmements qui les ont
précédés comme les responsabilités
collectives à l'origine des difficultés
actuel comme les ambitions pour les
sorties de crise l'image en Europe de
chacun de nos deux états et gagnera et
l'Europe
avec c'est au sein du couple du couple
franco-allemand dont le bon
fonctionnement est plus que jamais
nécessaire que s'est développé un double
débat sur les rôles et les engagements
respectifs de l'Europe et du FMI ainsi
que sur le caractère insuffisamment
porteur d'avenir de l'aide apportée à la
Grèce je pense que le FMI ne doit pas
être présenté comme venant se substituer
à une Europe inexistante il me semble
bien au contraire qu'il joue son rôle
normal au côté de l'Europe et en étroite
coordination avec elle le FMI c'est
également nous quant aux conditions de
l'aide nous avons compris qu'elle était
parfaitement harmonique is avec celle
présentée en taux variable par le FMI et
qu'elle inclut une marge pour couverture
d'un reliat de risque nous en donnons
acte non sans considérer que nous
sauvons la Grèce sans lui faire de vrais
cadeaux et surtout sans lui donner
complètement les moyens de repartir du
meilleur pied vers la croissance qui
seule la mettra durablement hors
d'affaair il n faudra rester attentif à
favoriser la Renaissance je me demande
s'il ne faut pas envoyer quelques siges
concret d'encouragement au peuple grec
afin qu'il accepte moins mal les
conditions très dures du plan que vient
d'adapter vous le rappeliez à l'instant
madame la ministre le Parlement d'Athène
si le plan reste refusé dans la rue la
Grèce se retrouvera bien seule face à un
destin foudroyé nous n'aurons pas à en
être fier et la contagion gagnera les
spéculateurs avec elle je cite
simplement ici le plan de rigueur assez
comparable mise en œuvre en lonie alors
que je m'inquiétais récemment à rard de
savoir comment un tel plan pouvait être
accepté il m'était répondu nous en avons
vu d'autres certes aucune situation
n'est transposable et je me garderai de
la transposer au cas de la Grèce puisse
simplement cette référence nous amener
au moins à relativiser ce qui peut
l'être notamment lorsque nous engageons
des réformes réputées difficiles dans
notre pays sur fond de difficulté au
Portugal en Espagne ou en Irlande sur
fond de difficulté à faire exister
solidairement et fortement l'Eurogroup
la crise que nous
traversons doit contribuer que que que
nous devons contribuer à éteindre à
tourner au drame hier du fait de
surenchè de casseurs elle est une
véritable épreuve pour une pour une
Grèce qui paye au prix fort des années
d'insuffisance elle est une épreuve pour
l'Euro devenu la la cible des
spéculateurs elle est une épreuve pour
l'Europe dont la cohésion est mise à mal
redonnons priorité au service de ces
deux filles de la Grèce que sont
l'Europe et la démocratie reprenons avec
courage et détermination la construction
exigeante monsieur le rapporteur général
d'une Europe qui répond à l'attente des
Européens et du monde alors cette crise
n'aura pas été complètement
veine je vous remercie chers collègues
la parole est à notre collègue madame
Nicole brick s'il vous
plaît
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans la phase d'accélération
de l'histoire où nous nous situons le
risque à prendre quand on prend la
parole et de se voir dépasser ou
démentir tant dans les affirmations que
dans les infirmation je commencerai donc
par les données objectives ce projet de
loi rectificative et motivé par le prêt
que la France consent à la Grèce à
hauteur de
16,8 milliards sur 3 ans et à
l'ouverture de crédit de paiement de 3
millards 9 en 2010 ce qui correspond à
sa participation au sein de la zone euro
logiquement le projet de loi de finance
rectificative adapte la prévision de
déficit de la loi de finance initiale en
ajoutant 3 milliards au déficit ce qui
le porte à 152 milliards mais j'ai noté
que le gouvernement laisser inchanger
son hypothèse de croissance 1,2 % alors
que l'INC a tablé récemment sur 0,9 et
que pour 2010 la Commission européenne
donne un chiffre voisin même si elle a
une prévision très inférieure à celle du
gouvernement pour
2011 nous verrons ce qu'il en sera euh
alors que le chômage perdure que la
consommation faiblit nous verrons cela
je n'en doute pas dans un prochain
PLFR le groupe socialiste votera ce
projet de loi de finance rectificative
en responsabilité soutenir la Grèce
c'est défendre la zone euro c'est
respecter les traités don la France est
signataire bref c'est être conséquent
avec l'engagement européen qui est le
nôtre même s'il y aurait beaucoup à dire
sur les orientations de l'Union
européenne tout au long de ces années
abordons maintenant la gestion de la
crise puisque l'objet du projet de loi
de finance rectificative est celui d'un
prêt à la Grèce dans le but de la
délivrer de l'emprise des marchés durant
une période critique estimée à 18 mois
alors on peut débattre de l'attentisme
et du manque de réactivité des États de
la zone euro en Allemagne certainement
où il a fallu que le directeur général
du FMI convaincre la chancelière de
l'urgence et de la hauteur de son
intervention et dans une mesure moindre
en France où l'accent a était d'abord
principalement mis sur les contreparties
plutôt que sur le soutien à la Grèce
lui-même cet attentisme se vérifie dans
le calendrier dès le 11 février 2010
lors du Conseil européen relatif à la
stratégie de croissance Europe 2020 les
États de l'Union européenne ayant
affirmé le principe de la solidarité
européenne avec la Grèce les
États-membres de la zone euro ont
déclaré qu'il prendrai des mesures
déterminées et coordonné si nécessaire
pour préserver la stabilité financière
de la zone euro dans son ensemble lors
du Conseil européen du 25 mars 2010 il a
été précisé que le soutien financier à
la Grèce interviendrait en dernier
recours en particulier si le financement
de marché devait se révéler insuffisant
dans le cadre d'un accord comprenant une
implication financière du FMI et une
majorité de financement européen par le
billet de prêts bilatéraux coordonné des
pays membres de la zone euro à partir du
début avril 2010 les doutes des
investisseurs ont ressurgi à la suite de
la dégradation de la notation des
banques grecques et de la demande par
celle-ci de l'activation du relicat du
plan de soutien aux banques qui avait
été mis en place par le gouvernement
grec les taux de financement ont atteint
le 8 avril 736 % soit un écart de taux
par rapport à l'Allemagne de 645 points
de base contre 400 points dans la
semaine précédente le doute s'est
instauré quant au caractère supportable
à moyen terme de telles conditions de
financement pour les finances publies
grec d'autant que les titres à
refinancer s'élevai pour avril 2010 à 12
milliards d'euros et pour mai 2010 à 8
milliards d'euros le 11 avril les
États-membres de la zone euro ont
confirmé le principe d'un plan de
soutien financier à la Grèce au cas où
l'accès du marché lui serait fermé
valable pour 3 ans pour un maximum de 30
milliards d'euros dès 2 10 à un taux de
5 % la Commission européenne s'est
engagée à élaborer le 12 avril et en
lien avec la BCE le FMI et le
gouvernement grec un programme
d'assistance à la Grèce le 21 avril vous
présentiez le projet de loi de finance
rectificative en conseil des ministres
et le 23 avril la Grèce a demandé
l'activation du plan européen d'aide
financière il n'est pas niable madame la
ministre que la sous-estimation du
risque grec après tout la Grèce n'est
pas d'un poids énorme dans l'économie de
l'Union les arrièrespensées liées à la
baisse de l'euro l'attentisme qui s'en
est suivi ont constitué une erreur
d'appréciation de la gravité de la
situation alors on peut débattre du
montant du prêt fixé à hauteur de 110
milliards pour la France à 16 milliards
800 millions suffira-t-il à atteindre
l'objectif ou sera-t-il côire sur une
jambe de bois la pluriannualité du plan
laisse ouverte la possibilité de faire
plus surtout s'il est nécessaire de
stopper l'effet de contagion car les
marchés même apaisé garderont toujours
l'œil ouvert on peut débattre du taux de
ce prêt largement supérieur au moins
pour l'Allemagne et la France à celui
auquel elle se refinance et surtout sa
hauteur à 5,2
% il faut la comparer à l'hypothèse de
croissance sur laquelle repose le plan
grec la Commission européenne a du reste
hier réviser cette hypothèse à la
baisse la récession est aggravé dans les
chiffres de la Commission européenne
pour la Grèce en 2010 al ce taux élevé
n'est pas un facteur de crédibilité car
il laisse en penser qu'en raison du
décalage avec la croissance grecque le
gouvernement grec aura du mal à honorer
ses remboursements il est certainement
je n'en doute pas le résultat d'une
négociation avec nos partenaires
européens mais il est éloigné d'un bon
calcul économique on ne peut un calcul
simple on rembourse d'autant mieux qu'on
est en capacité de produire des
richesses et donc d'obtenir de bonnes
rentrées fiscales en attendant les Grecs
sont soumis à un régime sévère
souhaitons que le remède ne tue pas le
malade car la Grèce est un pays
démocratique laissons au peuple grec sa
capacité de réaction et gardons-nous de
l'humilier car l'histoire nous a appris
que la mémoire des des peuples pardon
est certainement plus longue que celle
des marchés on peut débattre aussi du
facteur déclencheur qui a permis
d'aboutir après bien des tergiversation
à l'accord final de la zone euro et à ce
prêt gageons que l'intervention la
semaine dernière du directeur général du
Fond Monétaire International auprès de
la Banque centrale européenne et de la
chancellière allemande n'a pas été pour
dans cette conclusion j'ai souvenir
madame la ministre de votre invitation à
votre ministère à l'automne 2008 des
deux commissions des finances du
Parlement à l'occasion du passage à
Paris de Monsieur Dominique
strouscan il était déjà dans question
dans les
conversations de l'intervention du FMI
en Europe mais il s'agissait alors d'un
petit État Balt la onie par ailleurs
hors Z euro à laquelle le FMI devait
accorder un prêt à hauteur de dans un
premier temps de 1,7 milliards avant de
fournir au côté de l'Union européenne un
prêt plus ambitieux on ne prêta sans
doute guerre suffisamment attention au
cas lon pourtant ce pays qui était hors
de la zone euro avait choisi un mode de
change fixé à la zone euro dans le but
de gagner en crédibilité et de contenir
l'inflation la recette fut bonne dans un
premier temps mais l'explosion de la
bulle immobilière de sa bule immobilière
et l'effondrement du commerce
international le prire de plein fouet en
récession ce pays s'était engagé à un
plan drastique qui l'a conduit en 2009 à
une contraction de son PIB de 18 % et
les Lons ont payé cher très cher mon
collègue banré vient de le rappeler
alors leur situation économique a l'air
de se stabiliser et ils doivent
certainement ils le doivent certainement
à l'intervention précoce du FMI qui
depuis lur a aidé d'autres pays
européens je pense à la Roumanie à la
Bulgarie tout cela pour dire que le côté
Tartu qui consistait il y a encore
quelques semaines à dire que le FMI en
Europe et à forceorie en zone euro vous
n'y pensez pas a vécu on peut aussi
débattre des agences de notation dont la
brutalité a sucé de vivres réactions
mais faut-il rappeler les enseignements
que nous avions tiré les uns et les
autres dès
2008 lors de nos travaux dans le cadre
du
G24 parlementaire de la de des de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat notamment après
la chute de lman brosers nous avions
alors dénoncé les conflits d'intérêts
l'absence de transparence la négligence
avec laquelle les agences de notation
tenaient compte dans leur notes de
produits financiers de plus en plus
complexe l'exigence à leur endroit que
nous portions alors ne saurait être
mieux résumé qu'au travers de ce
qu'écrivait Didier Migot alors député
socialiste et président de la commission
des finances dans un
petituscule publié par la Fondation Jean
jorè que j'ai pris l'initiative de
relire pour ce débat il nous disait la
régulation public des agences de
notation est une nécessité à minima
devrait-être engagé la séparation de
leurs activités de conseil et de
notation des règles pourraient être
inspirées au travers d'une obligation
d'enregistrement des agences auprès d'un
régulateur européen et pour finir il y
défendait une solution ambitieuse celle
de la création d'une Agence européenne
qui veillerait à leur indépendance et à
leur transparence le règlement européen
du 12 novembre 2000
et seulement en voie d'acheminement dans
les états et devrait entrer en vigueur
le 16 juin prochain madame la ministre
vous avez déclaré à l'Assemblée l'avoir
transmis à l'Autorité des marchés
financiers mais faute de régulateur
européen c'est chaque autorité de marché
qui prendra le soin d'enregistrer et de
contrôler les agences et ce dispositif
lâche avec un accent hein comprenez bien
c'est-à-dire pas pas serré ne nous
rassure pas car il sera l'objet de
toutes les interprétations possibles en
fonction de chaque régulateur alors
aujourd'hui il est facile de criéer Arau
sur les agences de notation qui sont
finalement un thermomètre pas la maladie
il e mieux valu aller plus vite et plus
loin dans l'attente dans l'atteint des
objectifs que nous avions proclamés il y
a 2 ans et quand on regarde le bilan de
de l'Union européenne quant aux
préconisations qui ont été faites au
cours des G20 on voit bien que la
machine communautaire a du mal à suivre
alors on peut débattre aussi du rôle de
la Banque centrale européenne qui après
avoir ouvert les liquidités aux banques
européennes et celles-ci se sont
empressées d'acheter des obligations
d'État dont celle de la Grèce et
d'autres pays en difficulté et elle se
trouve aujourd'hui exposée à une hauteur
dont il faut reconnaître qu'on ne
connaît pas très bien la jauge la banque
centrale donc après ouvert les avoir
ouvert les vannes des liquidités a
franchi le Rubicon en assouplissant pour
la seule Grèce ses conditions
d'acceptation des obligations d'État
alors qu'en janvier encore le président
tricher affirmé nous ne changerons pas
nos systèmes de collatéraux pour le bien
d'un pays particulier cela éclaire comme
de l'eau de roche alors on peut peut
aussi débattre du pacte de stabilité
dont tout le monde s'est affranchi nous
savions bien qu'il y aurait un jour ou
l'autre un moment où la nouvelle bulle
des dettes souveraines nous poseraiit
des problèmes nous y sommes alors il est
vrai que les règles de la zone euro
était faite pour le beau temps pour une
mer tranquille pour l'harmonie
universelle pas pour affronter les
tempêtes on peut débattre enfin des
méchants marchés qui ne sont pas
reconnaissants aux états de les avoir
sauvés ce serait considéré les marchés
comme des êtres moraux ce qu'ils ne sont
pas cette posture nous confirme dans
notre impuissance à agir dans la
régulation financière obnubilé que sont
nous dirigeant dans le match Europe us
usa pardon États-Unis voire au sein de
l'union entre places financières celle
de Paris et celle de Londres
rappelons-nous du match de fond de cours
c'est bientôt l'ouverture de Roland
Garos pour mettre en œuvre une
maigrelette taxation des bonus comme de
celui que mène l'Europe au sujet de la
prévention du risque systémique chacun
attendant que l'autre monte au filet
pour pouvoir rabattre sa raquette mais
j'ai pas envie de rire l'heure est grave
même si les marchés se calment
gardons-nous de croire qu'une fois
l'incendie éteint la braise ne se
rallumera pas car le drame aujourd'hui
c'est que nous vivons une crise de
confiance générale et que ce qui
m'apparaît le plus grave c'est qu'il n'y
a plus de confiance entre les États au
sein de la zone euro alors une lettre
commune du président de la République et
de la chancelière au président de
l'Europe ne suffira pas à la retrouver
qu'ont-ils fait ses dirigeants ces
dernières années une course folle une
course à l'avantage compétitif une
course à la baisse de la fiscalité
surtout pour le capital une course à la
compression salariale au sein même de
l'Union européenne et de tels choix sont
politiques il en faut de nouveau pour
que l'Europe survive et bien sûr en son
sein la zone euro a pour élaborer de
nouvelles règles pour le PACT de
stabilité comme pour définir des normes
budgétaires il y aura du monde mais pour
dégager des solutions politiques celles
que réclame la gouvernance économique
l'harmonisation fiscale enfin un budget
européen qui donne à l'Europe la
capacité propre d'emprunter il faudra
plus que le talent des hauts
fonctionnaires il nous faudra des
dirigeants à la
hauteur le jugement de la gestion de
crise ne peut qu'être sévère nous avons
vu des gouvernant divisés hésitant et
quelquefois hypocrite la réalité nous la
connaissons l'Europe est malade de ses
déficit publ certes mais de son chômage
et de sa très faible croissance au
moment où se dessine le couple qualifié
de G2 États-Unis et Chine il est temps
de se ressaisir madame la ministre en
commission vous nous avez rappelé que le
traité de Lisbonne institutionnalise
l'Eurogroup il nous donnerait donc la
liberté d'aller de l'avant j'ai déjà
entendu cet argument dans mon camp et je
voudrais rappeler que les socialistes
réclament depuis des années sans trouver
jusqu'à présent d'éco ce gouvernement
économique dont tout le monde se fait
aujourd'hui le tarangon cela est plus
nécessaire que jamais de construire
cette gouvernance
que Monsieur le Ministre et Madame que
de se servir de la crise pour régler à à
la hussarde tel ou tel problème
domestique je veux parler bien sûr des
retraites et du gel des dépenses
annoncées par le Premier ministre sans
qu'il veille bien encore une fois
regarder du côté des recettes nous
continuerons ce débat alors pour
conclure sur une note peut-être un peu
plus positive je voudrais rappeler en 74
en
1974 dans la tourmente monétaire qui
suivait la crise ouverte en
1973 le secrétaire d'État
Kissinger avaittu cette formule méchante
l'Europe quel numéro de téléphone alors
les faits ne lui ont pas donné tout à
fait raison parce qu'il n'y avait
peut-être personne au téléphone mais il
y avait quelqu'un dans dans l'avion car
en 1976 les accords de la Jamaïque
étaient signés et en
1979 le SME était en place et
aujourd'hui c'est l'euro son successeur
finalement qui est dans la tourmente et
c'est les Europes l'Europe et les
Européens qui souffrent alors ce que
nous souhaitons nous socialistes c'est
que l'Europe soit pilotée et remise à
l'endroit
sur de bonnes bases celle de la
croissance et celle de la
justice je vous remercie ma chère
collègue la parole est à notre collègue
Daniel
Marsin monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues en 2004 la Grèce organisait
les Jeux Olympiques et offrait au me de
l'image d'un pays jeune dynamique
ambitieux et réconcilié avec son passé
elle accueillait dans un deur somptueux
dans une aviance festive les délégations
nationales et des spectateurs du monde
entier 6 ans après la graisse de nouveau
sous les feux des projecteurs médiatique
mais cette fois-ci est au bord du
désastre économique et financier à la
merci d'un destin tragique qu'elle ne
maîtrise plus et en tout cas qu'elle ne
maîtrise plus
seule deux difficultés majeures sont à
l'origine de cette situation difficulté
qu'il faut ici rappeler d'une part bien
sûr la crise financière internationale
qui a notamment fragilisé les économies
les plus viléble et d'autre part la
perte de crédibilité des deux derniers
gouvernements Grecs véritable poudrieur
politique que qui risque non seulement
de de de déstabiliser la société grecque
mais plus largement c'est partenaires de
la zone euro puisque nous le savons de
révision en révision de la prévision de
déficit grec et bien euh à chaque
révision cela a aggravé la défiance des
marchés à l'égard du pays et ça s'est
traduit par des écarts de taux de
financement considérable mais ce n'est
pas seulement la situation économique et
financière de la Grèce qui est en cause
c'est on l'a je crois c'est dit c'est
très clairement aussi la stabilité de
toute la zone euro dans ces conditions
il devient donc urgent pour l'ensemble
des pays de la zone euro d'intervenir et
de faire preuve de solidarité c'est donc
l'objectif de ce collectif budgétaire
que l'on pourrait qualifier d'inhabituel
en ce sens qu'elle propose d'octoyer en
tant que de besoin un prês de la France
à la Grèce pour un montant de 17
milliard peu près de 17 milliards
d'euros sur 3 ans mais le montant des
prédit de paiement l'a dit qui seront
versés en 2010 reste fixé 3 milliard 9
d'euros le principe directeur qui doit
aujourd'hui prévoaloir et nous le
convenons aément est celui de la
solidarité ce semble-t-il et cela nous
réjouit au
RDSE celui choisi par le gouvernement
qui aura probablement nous l'espérons en
tout cas l'accord et l'approbation du du
Parlement mais euh nous allons se
faisant affirmer avec force notre
engagement européen et c'est pour les
membres du du RDS à une constante et un
impératif dans la situation
actuelle je voudrais d'ailleurs rappeler
que dans un rapport qui a été effectué
il y a près de 3 ans par Yvan colollin
euh actuel président du RDSE bien on
avait déjà tiré la sonnette d'alarme en
soulignant le manque de coordination des
politiques économiques européennes cet
engagement est donc fondamental dans le
processus de constitution européenne et
qui qui est donc un principe de base et
bien semblait manquer et notre président
actuel l'avait déjà rappelé et puisque
nous y sommes aujourd'hui et bien euh
cela nous conduit à admettre que
l'avenir du vivre ensemble européen
passe par davantage de solidarité
d'entraide et de coordination entre les
États ce qui nous emmène également à
souligner que jusqu'aux derniers
événements Grecs les politiques
économiques dans l'Union européenne
particulièrement dans la zone euro
apparaissait au mieux désordonné et au
pire antagoniste aujourd'hui en deppis
de nombreux antagonismes fiscaux qui
demeurent la solidarité financière SEM
avoir pris le pas sur le repli égoïste
le RDSE s'en félicite et notre soutien à
la Grèce est un impératif de solidarité
un impératif économique soutenir la
Grèce bâtir ce mécanisme de rempart que
nous avons construit avec le concours du
Fond Monétaire International c'est aussi
une façon de stabiliser l'euro et de
renforcer la zone euro la stabilité de
l'euro est fortement mise en cause nous
le savons par la crise grecque comme en
témoigne la dégringolade de l'euro
vis-à-vis du dollar et la chuteite des
Bourses européennes encore accentué ces
derniers jours et
pourtant on l'a dit l'Union européenne
est intervenu trop tardivement cette
réactivité trop lente demeure une erreur
qu'il faudra corriger dans
l'avenir dès janvier 2010 la spéculation
avait commencé et il a fallu attendre le
courant du avril au moment où l'État
grec devait déjà faire face à des
remboursements importants pour que soit
annoncé un engagement européen plus
solidaire par ailleurs la réaction de la
Banque centrale européenne regrettant
que le FMI soit sollicité ne peut
manquer d'interroger comment une banque
centrale qui refinance au tau de 1 % les
banques qui ell-même finance des
spéculateurs ne pourrait appliquer un
taux de refinancement aussi avantageux à
un état cette question mérite tout de
même d'être posée désormais l'Europe
doit tirer les son de la crise
financière dont nous sommes
malheureusement pas encore sortis il en
découle donc deux réflexions en premier
lieu en premier lieu dans un récent
entretien accordé à un grand quotidien
économique le commissaire européen
chargé des marchés financiers Michel
Barnier affirmait que je cite puisque la
tempête qui s'abat sur l'Europe est la
faute des agences de notation
américaines qui ont injustement dégrader
la note des cigales européennes il faut
envisager la création d'une agence de
notation européenne pour redresser ce
tort
considérable en tout cas le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que d'une part ces
agences ne sont pas tout à fait euh
échappent en tout cas au contrôle de
régulateurs euh officiel et en tout cas
tous les gendarmes boursiers qui soi
d'ailleurs américains ou européens et
que d'autre part leur bilan est loin
d'être probant car nous savons quelques
jours à peine avant la faillite de la
banque américaine lban Bros bien une
dans de ces agences et bien affirmer
maintenir son soutien et sa confiance à
la direction financière de la Banque on
en a encore d'ailleurs d'autres exemples
mais le plus gros problème est ailleurs
c'est la question de savoir qui rémunère
ces agences et ne sont ne sont pas
d'ailleurs les émetteurs de dett
eux-mêmes d'où le risque que certains
ont évoqué tout à l'heure de conflit
d'intérêt les agences de notation en
tout cas qui ont accentué la volat ité
des marchés financiers ces derniers
jours doivent donc être mieux contrôlé
on l'a dit il a r on déstabiliser la
Grèce et on le voit bien aujourd'hui
elles sont en train de déstabiliser
l'Espagne et le Portugal on peut
s'interroger de main sur notre pays en
second lieu et bien il est également
évident
que que l'Europe a besoin de
gouvernement économique le gouvernement
économique démocratique qui s'appuyait
sur le principe de la solidarité
budgétaire là aussi on l'a dit et au RDS
nous le pensons et nous le pensons
profondément même si cette solidarité
suppose l'effort la fermeté dans les
principes mais cette solidarité nous
semble absolument indispensable et et
donc c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que nous
pensons que au-delà de cette solidarité
après il faudra veiller que les
engagements pris par la Grèce soi
correctement respecté en tout cas
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur le
Ministre
et bien nous au RDS nous voterons ce
texte parce que nous pensons qu'il
correspond d'abord à un devoir de
solidarité mais parce que aussi nous
sommes profondément européens et nous
commençons que c'est dans le besoin
qu'on reconnaît ses amis et donc avec
toutes les réserves que nous avons pu
exprimer les questionnements que nous
avons également exprimés nous voterons
ce texte parce que nous sommes des
ordant défenseur de l'idée européenne je
vous
remercie
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à notre collègue Bernard
verra monsieur le Président Madame et
monsieurs les ministres mes chers
collègu il aura donc suffi de 20
milliards d'euros représentant le défaut
de paiement potentiel de l'État
grec pour que en quelques jours
l'édifice de la construction européenne
montre des signes évidents
d'essoufflement et de
fragilité 20 milliards d'euros alors
même qu'en 2009 compte tenu de la
récession internationale les 16 pays de
la zone euro ont produit pour plus de
12500 milliards de dollars de biens et
de services autant dire que l'impasse
budgétaire dans laquelle la Grèce s'est
retrouvée ne représente en réalité qu'un
petit grand sable et pourtant ce grain
de sable a suffi pour que la belle
mécanique européenne connaisse une
incroyable crise systémique dont nous
n'avons sans doute pas encore vu toutes
les
implications ainsi parce que l'État grec
risquait de se trouver dans l'incapacité
de rembourser quelques bandquers cupides
qui l'ont pourtant rançonné avec des
taux d'intérêt
exorbitants nous avons eu droit à 2 mois
de valse hésitation des gouvernements
européens à l'affirmation des égoïsmes
et des positions conditionnées par des
considérations de politique intérieure
et à l'évidence chaque jour plus
clairire d'une crise obligataire
grandissante chacun avait en effet dans
cette affaire ses propres
préoccupations l'Irlande l'Italie le
Portugal et l'Espagne cible de la
spéculation financière internationale
mettent péniblement en œuvre des mesures
d'ajustement de leurs compte public
parce qu'ils sont à l'instar de 13 des
16 pays de l'urollande l'objet d'une
procédure pour déficit public
excessif pendant ce temps-là la Belgique
qui échappe pour l'heure à la crise
obligataire continue de se déliter au
fil de l'aiguisement de ses antagonismes
régionaux et l'Allemagne quant à elle
qui ne s'est jamais acquité de la
facture des dommages de guerre causés
entre 19
et 1944 à la Grèce a sans cesse
conditionné l'engagement de son pays à
l'exigence de toujours plus de sacrific
de la part du peuple grec dans cet
ensemble la France aurait pu avoir une
attitude différente de celle qui a été
choisie en effet ce collectif se prépare
à apporter 3,9 milliards de droits de
tirage immédiat à l'état grec prêté à un
taux de 5 % pour qu'il ait la possibil
de permettre à la Société Générale de
recouvrer les 3 milliards de créances
douteuses qu'elle a sur la dette
publique grecque et d'offrir au crédit
agricoles l'opportunité d'éviter
l'imputation de 800 millions des mêmes
créances en résumé l'État français va
s'endetter pour permettre à nos
établissements de CR de crédit d'éviter
des pertes de
créances était-il
inconcevable que les banques qui ont
souscrit une bonne partie de la dette
publique grec contribue à l'effort
général en réchelonnant par exemple
elle-même la dette voire en consentant
des abandons de créances ainsi tout est
dit ou presque du contenu de ce pseudo
dispositif d'aide à la Grèce qui est au
fond une répétition du plan de soutien
aux banques sans exigence d'aucune
contribution ni d'aucune
contrepartie tous ces dispositifs n'ont
rien à voir avec la prétendue solidarité
que l'Europe affirmerait avec avec ce
pseudo plan d'aide ce qui nous est en
effet proposé consiste en réalité à
faire porter par les dettes publiques
les créances douteuses que les banques
et les compagnies d'inurance ont sur la
dette publique
grecque pire même avec ce plan le risque
de défaut grec est transféré sur les
états et ce sont les contribuables
français allemands ou néerlandais qui
seront éventuellement sollicités dans 3
ans si la Grèce ne peut pas ne peut pas
payer la véritable solidarité avec le
peuple grec c'est celle que nous portons
et qui vise à entendre les attentes et
les aspirations populaires notamment
quand les plus riches les profiteurs de
la crise les financiers et les banquiers
se trouvent exonérés du moindre effort
en Grèce comme en
France je voudrais maintenant m'arrêter
quelques instant sur les raisons qui à
notre sens ont conduit à cette situation
depuis son adhésion à l'Union européenne
en
1981 la Grèce a en effet connu plusieurs
phases dans sa participation à la
construction
européenne bénéficiire net des subsides
européens situation que les retards
économiques du pays pouvaient largement
justifier son relatif développement
économique récent a été gagé sur une
plus grande intégration et une plus
grande dépendance de secteurs clés de
son économie vis-à-vis de l'étranger si
le revenu des habitants du pays s'est
accru en restant inférieur à la moyenne
des pays de l'Union et plus encore des
pays de la zone euro nombre de secteurs
stratégiques ont été progressivement ou
totalement privatisé tandis que les
salariés Grecs goûtaient amèrement aux
conséquences de la déflation salariale
et de la
flexibilité c'est ainsi que les
principales banques grecques sont
passées sous le contrôle d'établissement
d'autres pays comme la BNP la Société
Générale ou le Crédit Agricole que
l'opérateur historique de
télécommunication est devenu propriété
de Dutch Telecom pour 30 % de son
capital que l'opérateur national
d'électricité est devenu à plus de 45 %
par des investis est détenu pardon à
plus de 45 % par des investisseurs
institutionnels et que la compagnie
aérienne nationale a été vendue à un
consortium privé ajoutons que sous les
gouvernements Caraman Liss ayant géré
les affaires du pays de 2004 à 2009 le
système fiscal a connu une série de
réformes à sens unique allégeant les
l'impôt sur les sociétés les tranches
supérieures de l'impôt sur les revenus
maintenant l'exonération de la taxation
des dividendes réduisant les droits
pesants sur les mutations donations et
succession toutes mesures qui
s'inscrivent dans la même logique que
celle prise dans notre pays notamment
depuis
2007 de fait la Grèce aujourd'hui
condense ce qui est la résultant des
choix européens critères de convergence
inatteignable concurrence entre les
territoires et les peuples soumission à
la dictature des marchés financiers
autisme d'une banque centrale européenne
rivée sur son objectif unique de
stabilité des
prix d'autres choix auraient pu être
fait y compris dans notre pays il n'est
pas normal que l'État s'en dette et
s'ppauvrisse pour venir au secours des
banques sans contrepartie
les créanciers de la Grèce doivent
mettre la main au
porte-monnaie au lieu de solliciter
l'endettement des États-membres de la
zone euro il aurait peut-être été censé
que la Banque centrale européenne mette
autour de la table les banques et
compagnies d'assurance largement aidé en
2008 et 2009 pour qu'elles prennent à
leur charge une partie du défaut grec
quand on pense que l'État grec a avancé
30 milliards d'euros pour préserver son
secteur fin domestique on mesure ce que
représentent les échéances en souffrance
et comme nos comptes publics sont mis à
mal nous devons dégager de suite de
nouvelles ressources pour éviter que le
syndrome grec ne finisse un jour par
nous
atteindre ce n'est pas dans le dumping
social et fiscal ni dans la réduction de
la dépense publique ni dans le
financement exclusive des dettes
publiques par les marchés que nous
redonnerons à l'Europe corps et sens
pour nos compatriotes
le mythe de la stabilité économique de
l'Union vient de partir en fumée c'est
la grande leçon de cette crise loin
d'être dédoué par ce projet de loi ce
texte replié sur la préservation de la
rentabilité des marchés assorti de
mesures d'austérité les plus dures que
le peuple grec a eu à subir depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale va contribuer à
plonger ce pays dans une récession très
grave et dommageable pour toute
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues nous
nous y opposerons donc sans la moindre
équivoque je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Robert
delpicaa vous parole mon cher
collègue bien alors monsieur le
Président Madame ministre monsieur
monsieur le ministre et mes chers
collègues alors le rapporteur général
l'a dit c'est le deuxe collectif
budgétaire de cette année mais peut-être
le rappeler c'est le 4ème collectif lié
à la crise
financière alors malgré les longues
tergisation de l'Allemagne en
particulier notamment pour les raisons
sous-jacentes de politique intérieure on
va peut-être y revenir l'Union
européenne est parvenue à un accord pour
un plan de sauvetage coordonné avec la
FMI il est vrai alors de quoi s'agit-il
et bien faut être clair et ne pas avoir
peur des mots il s'agit d'un plan sans
précédent pour sauver tout simplement de
la banque route la plus vieille
démocratie européenne tout simplement
alors un plan ne suffit pas il faut la
réussite de ce plan elle est essentielle
sans quoi mes chers collègues il n'est
pas certain qu'un deuxième plan de
sauvetage sera possible alors on a
constaté ces derniers jours à quel point
les marchés étaient fébriles et et on le
sait leur attention se porte déjà sur
l'Espagne le Portugal peut-être même
l'Italie qui serait soumis à des
spéculations encore plus véhémentes si
les finances de la Grèce ne parvenaient
pas à se relever et tout le monde serait
un peu responsable les Grecs bien sûr
mais aussi les autres ne pas réagir et
l'effet boule de neige serait sans nul
doute irréversible alors devant
l'urgence de la situation il est à
souligner mes chers
collègues que la France apparaî en
position d' tive et de moteur
puisqu'elle est le premier pays membre
de la zone euro à présenter son plan
national d'aide à l'État élénnique sous
la forme d'un collectif budgétaire mais
alors en quoi consiste cette aide on a
entendu elle prend la forme de
prébilatéraux coordonnés dans le cadre
d'un accord intergouvernemental sous
l'égide de la Commission européenne et
bien sûr en liaison avec le FMI alors la
contrepartie car il y a une contrepartie
la contrepartie de cette aide c'est la
mise en uvre par la Grèce d'un plan de
ur et d'assainissement de ces finances
publiques alors madame la ministre vous
l'a annoncé ce plan a été adopté donc ce
soir je crois par le Parlement grec mais
si on regarde un peu de plus près les
difficultés économiques de la Grèce les
difficultés financières aussi et bien
elles sont même antérieures à la crise
une administration clientéliste le fléau
de la corruption qui aurait coûté un
milliard de dollars à l'économie grecque
en 2009 une industrie subventionnée
excessiv par l'État un double marché du
travail à la fois légal et illégal une
forte perte de compétitivité qui a
entraîné une détérioration de son solde
commercial et un déficit extérieur
important alors ce n'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est le FMI tout simplement je ne
fais que répéter ajoutons que l'entrée
de la Grèce dans l'Union européenne puis
dans la zone euro lui avait permis à la
fois de faire reposer très largement sa
croissance sur les seuls fonds
structurels mais aussi d'emprunter à des
taux plus bas si bien si bien que ce
pays n'a pas fait les efforts de rigueur
nécessaires et a vu son endettement
exploser jusqu'à déper dépasser les 100
% de son PIB avant même l'éclatement de
la crise
financière alors la dette comme d'autres
pays du sud de l'Europe a subi de plein
fouet la crise financière économique
apparu après la faillite de la banque
lman Brothers en septembre 2008 avec une
forte dégradation de ces conditions
relatives de financement à cela
c'est'est ajouté une irresponsabilité
conduisant à un manque de rigueur pour
ne pas dire une falsification de ces
statistiques à l'automne dernier par
exemple le gouvernement grec estimit son
déficit public national à 6 % du PIB
alors qu'il a voisiné en réalité les 13
%. mais il ne s'agit pas d'un cas isolé
car déjà en 2004 et 2008 le pays avait
tronqué ses chiffres entraînant une
crise de confiance des marchés lors de
leur révision à la hausse les l'État
grec a été en outre victime on le sait
de la spéculation les marchés ont parié
sur les difficultés pour la zone euro
d'un éventuel défaut de la Grèce la
dégradation de sa note par une agence de
notation au pire moment alors que cet
état se retrouve fortement affaiblie n'a
fait qu'ajouter à la crise ou même de la
crise à la crise face à ce constat il
importait pour l'Union européenne et en
particulier l'Eurogroup de réagir alors
pourquoi mes chers collègues et bien
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord au titre
des valeurs fondatrices de l'Union au
premier rang desqueles figure la
solidarité Robert Schuman père fondateur
de l'Europe préconiser une solidarité de
fait ce principe de solidarité a été
posé dès le mois de février par les pays
membres de la zone euro à l'initiative
rappelons-le du président Sarkozi mais
au-delà de cette exigence de solidarité
prime encore davantage l'impératif
économique la banque-route de ce pays
remettrait en cause la stabilité de la
zone euro voire la monnaie unique
elle-même l'abandon par la zone euro
d'un de ses membres outre le fait qu'il
plongerait la Grèce dans une situation
inextricable pourrait constituer un
effet boule de neige comme ce fut le cas
lors de la faillite de Leman Brothers en
envoyant un signal désastreux qui
favoriserait l'offensive financière
contre d'autres États comme le Portugal
ou l'Espagne alors gardons-nous de
commettre deux fois la même
en laissant couler l Brothers c'est tout
le système bancaire qui s'est défendré
comme un château de carte ou plutôt des
dominau en outre un défaut de la Grèce
serait très douloureux pour les porteurs
de la dette de la Grèce or ces
créanciers mes chers collègues sont les
banques et assurance étrangère à 74 %
notamment française allemande et
italiennes qui se remettent tout juste
de la crise des subprimes même si ces
banques et assurances ont depuis la
crise couvert une partie de leur
portefeuille obligataire par des titres
fonctionnants comme des assurances
contre le risque de défaut des fameux
CDs le cludier défut swap je ne vais pas
don revenir sur les chiffres bien sûr
François Barin nous les a donné monsieur
le ministre vous n avez bien expliqué le
groupe um se félicite que l'amendement
du Gouvernement présenté à l'Assemblée
nationale a été voté par no collègue
députés afin de tenir compte des
résultats de l'accord conclu le 2 mai
par les ministres des Finances de la
zone euro alors l'aide française on le
sait maintenant est porté à 16,8
milliards sur 3 ans mais mes chers
collègues il faut pas se faire trop
d'illusion ces 3 années ne suffiront
sans doute pas et l'aide pourra être
prolongée il était en tout cas important
de donner plus de visibilité à notre
action à moyen terme afin de rassurer
les marchés et de tenter de faire SP en
tout cas de tenter de faire cesser la
spéculation alors cette aide financière
ne va pas impacter nos finances
publiques puisqu'elle prend la forme de
prêt comme l'a expliqué le
ministre alors nos compatriotes se pose
une
question est-ce que nous allons perdre
de l'argent et beaucoup d'argent dans
cette affaire et bien de la même manière
que l'aide financière aux banques
consenti sous la forme de prêt avec
intérêt avait rapporté 2 milliards aux
caisses de l'État c'est prês à la Grèce
devait même rapporter plusieurs
centaines de millions et puis il y a les
5 % c'est un débat qu'on nous met sur le
tapis de temps en temps et bien le taux
de 5 % a été décidé par la réunion des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement et on ne
peut pas le remettre en cause dans les
parlements
nationaux certains membres de
l'opposition comme en France notamment
communiste juge ce taux usuraire pour sa
part mes chers collègues le groupe um
approuve ce taux c'est le fruit d'un
équilibre cela nos concitoyens le
comprennent parce que
il convient de noter que si la Grèce
parvenait de nouveau à se financer sur
les marchés et bien elle devrait
emprunter à plus de 12 %. ce taux non
concessionnel fixe à 5 % sur 3 ans et
ensuite pe ou pro équivalent au taux
consenti par la FMI à taux variable et
puis enfin mes chers collègues il n pas
imaginable de proposer à la Grèce qui a
commis les graves erreurs de gestion de
ses finances public un taux plus
avantageux que ce bénéficiant à de
meilleurs élèves de la zone eururos qui
ont fait des efforts ça personne ne le
comprendrait CEO est d'ailleurs le
résultat d'un consensus entre pays
membres de
l'Eurogroupe et puis le groupe UMP
partage l'opinion du gouvernement selon
laquelle ce tau de 5 % correspond à une
rémunération du risque mais chers
collègues on a entendu la France n'a
donc pas besoin de modifier son
programme d'emprunt ce dont le groupe
UMP se félicite aussi en contrepartie de
cette aide sans précédent la Grèce a
pris des engagement ferme pour redresser
la situation de ces finances publiques
le plan de rigueur si on regarde en
détail je vais regarder il y a le
maintien du gel des salaires de la
fonction publique jusqu'en 2014 la
suppression des primes de vacances pour
de nombreux employés la suppression de
13e et 14e mois de salaire des
fonctionnaires la réduction des montants
des retraites l'augmentation de la
limite d'âge de départ la retraite et
puis la hausse de la TBA de 1 à 2 points
le gouvernement grec s'est engagé dans
la lutte contre la
corruption alors mais c'est une idée
monsieur le Président il est certain
qu'il s'agit d'effort particulièrement
important demander au Grecs le respect
de ce plan est évidemment
primordial nous nous félicitons Madame
et Monsieur le Ministre qu'un contrôle
trimestriel soit prévu et que vous
viendrez nous en rapporter tous les 3
mois à peu près et je crois que le
Parlement en sera euh très très non
seulement honoré mais en tout cas très
bien informé alors indéniablement cette
crise grecque met en lumière les
divergences européennes et la nécessité
mes chers collègues on a entendu
d'améliorer rapidement la gouvernance
économique de l'Union et je dis
gouvernance et non pas le gouvernement
économique parce que là nos amis
allemands s'élèvent fortement contre ce
terme et pour eux il s'agit de
gouvernance afin de donner satisfaction
à une opinion publique farouchement
allergique à tout laxisme et attaché à
la stabilité financière la chancellière
allemande Angela Merkel a fait preuve
d'une intransigence qui a entraîné de
longues discussions quant à la stratégie
à adopter mes chers collègues j'ai de la
famille en Allemagne qui sont allemands
et qui me font part de leurs étatâ les
efforts
consentis le sérieux de leur gestion les
efforts financiers les efforts dans le
domaines des impôts sont très durs et
ils acceptent assez mal de voir que les
pays qui qui ne sont pas suffisamment
sérieux
soit sous l'aide de l'Allemagne mais
aussi des autres pays européens mais il
faut peut-être ajouter aussi et il faut
être réaliste en politique c'est qu'il y
a une situation politique délicate en
Allemagne la chancelière se trouve en
effet à la tête d'un gouvernement de
coalition vous le savez et prépare une
importante élection régionale en ranie
du Nord
vestphaliie la lenteur de la réponse
coordonnée a été stigmatisée car les
marchés ont pu spéculer sur les
certitude et les vies au niveau européen
je vais pas rappeler tous les chiffres
c'était 20 milliards en février 30 en
avril 60 en avril même 60 en mai et on
est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je crois à
110 milliards d'euros donc il s'agit
d'améliorer la réactivité en réduisant
les divergences mais mieux coordonner
nos politiques comme l'a dit le
rapporteur général la Commission
européenne y travaille et devrait faire
une communication ce mois-ci je crois
que nous y serons très attentifs et la
commission des finances en particulier
il faut également améliorer la fiabilité
des statistiques économiques Eurostat
pourrait jouer un rôle déterminant dans
ce domaine le groupe UMP soutient l'idée
portée par le rapporteur toujours d'en
faire une autorité européenne
indépendante des comptes publics il
semble aussi indispensable d'assurer une
meilleure coordination entre le PACT de
stabilité et les lois nationales de
programmation des finances publiques
monsieur le rapporteur je crois qu'on
est d'accord là-dessus aussi et puis
mais presque enfin une plus grande et je
peux pas parler des Français l'étrangers
enfin une plus grande régulation
financière est indispensable et
notamment un contrôle des agents de
notation là je crois aussi qu'il y a
quelque chose à faire et en ce sens le
projet de loi de régulation bancaire et
financière qui devrait être examiné en
juin par l'Assemblée nationale devra
apporter des réponses enfin il est
également évoqué la possibilité de créer
un fond monétaire européen alors là mes
chers collègues madame monsieur le
ministre le groupe um je dois le dire
n'a pas d'avvis tranché sur cette
question mais par contre juge qu'il
serait opportun d'engager prochainement
une réflexion plus approfondie sur ce
point madame la ministre à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez annoncé que vous
prendriez très prochainement les
dispositions nécessaires pour
autoriser l'Autorité des marchés
financiers à contrôler les agents de
notation et à vérifier notamment qu'elle
respecte les règles déontologie le
groupe UMP vous soutiendra fermement
dans cette démarche
et le Conseil européen de demain mes
chers collègues sera également
déterminant il est absolument primordial
que nous retrouvions mes chers collègues
cette capacité d'anticipation qui ne
doit pas être le seul apanage des seuls
financiers je remerci de votre
attention je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre-Bernard
rmond
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'Europe progresse par des crises dit-on
celle que nous traversons est
particulièrement grave mais à plusieurs
titres riche d'enseignement et je
l'espère porteuse de nouveaux progrès
l'enfant chéri de l'Europe le berceau de
notre civilisation par son laxisme et sa
dissimulation s'est exposé aux assauts
de la spéculation au point de mettre en
péril et l'euro et l'Europe à elle
incombe la première des
responsabilités mais cette crise révèle
aussi notre erreur collective d'avoir
créé une monnaie unique orpheline d'un
vrai pouvoir économique et politique il
était légitime au moment de la création
de l'euro que l'on souhaite d'abord et
avant tout une banque centrale
parfaitement indépendante
l'Allemagne n'aurait d'ailleurs jamais
accepté d'abandonner le marc sans cela
mais cette indépendance aujourd'hui
encore absolument justifié et nécessaire
ne postuz pas que l'on se dispense dans
le même temps d'un pouvoir politique et
économique fort à la mesure de
l'ambition que représente la création
d'une monnaie unique à l'époque nous
n'avons fait que la moitié du chemin et
nous en payons le prix
aujourd'hui par la suite le pacte de
stabilité s'est non seulement révélé
insuffisant mais à vrai dire aucune
autorité réelle n'existait pour le faire
respecter pire à tour de rôle les États
se sont entendus pour le
transgresser nous payons aujourd'hui
cette faiblesse au prix fort sans savoir
exactement ce soir au moment où nous
débattons quel sera exactement l'ampleur
des conséquences de nos
faiblesses l'Europe a d'abord manqué de
transparence chaque état a considéré
comme une atteinte trop forte à sa
souveraineté le seul fait d'ouvrir ses
comptes tous ses comptes à ses
partenaires l'Europe a également manqué
de
lisibilité des appareils statistiques
trop différents n'ont pas permis de lire
et de juger les décisions et les
résultats de chacun de façon
suffisamment
standardisé l'Europe a manqué
d'homogénéité sur le plan économique
laissant les écart de compétitivité
s'accroître et se dissimuler sous le
voile plus ou moins pudique des bulles
financières immobilière et
budgétaire l'Europe a manqué de force
pour introduire plus de discipline dans
cet univers de libéralisme et de
nationalisme qui se sont curieusement
conjugué pour interdire l'élaboration
d'une vraie gouvernance
européenne l'Européen est convaincu que
je suis n'ira pas jusqu'à dire qu'il ne
fallait pas créer la monnaie unique s'il
en était pas capable de l'accompagner
d'une politique économique plus intégré
mais en fait c'est un peu cela en tout
cas l'euro aujourd'hui existe il a
montré son utilité et il représente une
réussite majeure
mais aujourd'hui il révèle aussi ses
faiblesses il faut de toute urgence
combler ce déséquilibre entre le
monétaire et l'économique et doter
concrètement l'Europe d'un pouvoir
économique beaucoup plus intégré sans se
laisser prendre au piège de la
sémantique entre la gouvernance et le
gouvernement s'interroger sur l'attitude
des agences de notation en période de
crise et sur le contrôle que l'on doit
exercer sur elle à défaut de se doter
d'un organisme public au niveau mondial
ou régional redéfinir le rôle de
l'Eurostat s'interroger sur l'éventuel
élargissement des missions de la Cour
des comptes
européennne mettre en place des
procédures de prévention d'alerte et de
sauvetage pour augmenter le taux de
réactivité en cas de difficulté mettre
en place une procédure de contrôle des
déficits public de chacun des États et
soumettre leur projet de budget à la vie
d'un Eurogroupe renforcé s'interroger
sur la nécessité de mettre en place un
Fond Monétaire Européen aider au
rapprochement des compétitivités
respectives et comprendre qu'à l'ère de
la mondialisation il est indispensable
et plus qu'urgent de bâtir des
politiques budgétaire fiscal industriel
et de recherche beaucoup plus intégré
tant il est vrai que la taille de chacun
de nos états ne correspond plus aux
exigences de la compétition à laquelle
nous confronteront de plus en plus des
états continents et de grands pays
émergents qui ont décidé de se lancer
eux aussi avec succès et en toute
légitimité dans l'aventure de la
croissance fut-elle durable voici me
semble-t-il une série de mesures
auxquelles nous devons
réfléchir certaines d'entre elles
peuvent être mises en œuvre à
législation
constante d'autres réclameront peut-être
de nouveaux traités et
vraisemblablement de nouveaux transferts
de souveraineté n'ayons pas peur notre
avenir est à ce prix nous savons que
Monsieur van ronpoy doit annoncer des
propositions avant la fin de l'année
n'est-ce pas un peu trop lointain la
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat à l'initiative de son président
Jean biset aimerait également réfléchir
à cette question et nous vous remercions
Madame la ministre d'avoir accepté de
venir nous en
entretenir vous comprendrez madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre que
j'approuve totalement les mesures que
vous nous proposez pour aider la Grèce
dans ces moments difficile en espérant
que la solidarité européenne tarira le
flux de la spéculation et permettra à ce
pays de retrouver la voix d'une
croissance saine dans un concert
européen qui aura qui aura su tirer
toutes les leçons de cette crise et se
doter d'un véritable gouvernement
économique je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est au gouvernement
madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
je vais répondre à certaines de vos
interventions mais avant cela je tenais
à adresser mes remerciements à
l'ensemble des
groupes ceux qui ont exprimé en tout cas
leur soutien à ce projet de loi et qui
ont indiqué qu'il le voteraient dans un
souci de responsabilité et de solidarité
qu'ils en souhaitent ici
remercier monsieur le rapporteur général
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
propositions et je souhaiterais tout
particulièrement retenir celle que vous
avez for formulé relativ à des normes
comptables qui viseraient non pas les
entreprises privées mais les États et
donc des normes de comptabilité publique
qui permettrait une harmonisation de la
façon dont il est rendu compte des
actifs des passifs des états ce qui
aujourd'hui présente indéiablement une
difficulté si l'on en juge par les
commentaires d'Eurostat aussi bien
auprès de votre commission lorsqu'ils
ont été entendus qu'à l'occasion des
auditions qu'ils ont pu donner également
au niveau européen donc c'est une
proposition tout à fait intéressante au
même titre qui est intéressante monsieur
le Président la vôtre consistante à
développer et agrandir le champ de
compétences de la Cour des comptes
européennes ainsi que d'envisager des
contrôles croisés auquels
participeraient des Cours des comptes
nationales qui viendrai donc examiner
les comptes d'autres États euh de
manière confraternelle si j'ose dire
entre entre comptable public donc ces
deux ces deux propositions euh je je
vous en remercie d'abord et je vous
indique que je les transmettrai euh au
groupe de travail présidé par Monsieur
van rampoy dans le cadre de la série des
améliorations de gouvernance euh qu'il
qu'il a pour charge de proposer alors
euh tout à l'heure le délai de la fin de
l'année ass semblé à l'un d'entre vous
si je me souviens bien un peu court et
je vous l'accorde attendre la fin de
l'année 2010 pour faire un certain
nombre de propositions d'amélioration
semble bien lointain surtout lorsque
l'on sa que la Commission elle-même est
chargée de faire une communication dans
des délais beaucoup plus brefs et qu'il
serait évidemment souhaitable que le
groupe de travail sous présidence van
rompoy et la communication sous
l'autorité de la Commission puisse au
moins converger et se rapprocher dans le
temps c'est une proposition que là aussi
je je je transmettrai parce qu'elle me
paraît tout à fait
judicieuse vous avez
été un certain nombre à commenter le le
le calcul des intérêts et je voudrais
pour un instant m'arrêter sur cette
question qui a
été qui a donné lieu à des qualificatifs
probablement un peu excessifs je
voudrais simplement vous rappeler
que les principes que nous avons
souhaité appliquer en matière de
fixation des intérêts étent assez simple
le premier principe c'était que nous
souhaitions que l'ensemble des pays de
l'Eurogroupe puisse pratiquer le même
taux deuxièmement nous souaitions nous
aligner le plus possible sur le taux
pratiqué par le Fond Monétaire
International et dans ces conditions
qu'il s'agisse d'un taux fixe par
hypothèse plus élevé comparé à un taux
qui est généralement variable lorsqu'il
est servi par le Fond Monétaire
lorsqu'il est demandé par le Fond
Monétaire International ou qu'il
s'agisse d'un taux variable nous sommes
à 0,25 points près pratiquement sur les
mêmes taux que le Fond Monétaire
International ça nous est paru juste
parce que tout simplement nous étions
cofinanceurs sur le même programme avec
les mêmes conditionnalit et que dans ces
conditions il était souhaitable que nous
soyons dans l'épaisseur du trait certes
le plus proche possible du Fond
Monétaire International et puis
troisième principe qui nous a gué guidé
celui qu'évoquait tout à
l'heure l'un d'entre vous c'est c'est le
principe de l'équité il aurait tout de
même été étrange que l'on offre une des
conditions de financement à la Grèce par
exemple qui auraient été à des
taux plus favorables à ceux auxquels par
exemple d'autres pays dit de périphérie
se financent alors qu'ils ont été
infiniment plus plus réguliers plus
vertueux et plus honnête dans le
compte-rendu de leur de leur compte donc
dans ces conditions-là il nous paraît
légitime de proposer ce taux d'intérêt
dont je rappelle que en tau fixe il est
à peu près de 5 % non pas de 5,2 et
qu'en variable il serait de l'ordre de
4,2 la première année 3,7 les années
suivantes ce qui franchement n'est pas
très loin du taux pratiqué par le Fond
Monétaire
International vous avez été nombreux
également à évoquer la question des
agences de notation et je voudrais
rappeler que quel que soit
l'appréciation lâche ou pas lâche du du
du du du filet que nous essayons de
mettre en place c'est sous présidence
française en 2008 et à l'occasion donc
d'une des premières réunions que nous
avons tenu sous présidence française que
nous avons engagé ce chantier de
l'enregistrement de la réglementation du
contrôle de la séparation des
différentes activités de la nécessité de
déposer les modèles les qui qui servent
au au calcul effectués par les agences
de notation et que c'est le processus
européen qui entre juillet 2008 et
novembre 2009 nous a amené à avoir un
texte qui sera applicable en France à
partir du 7 juin 2010 j'ai à cet égard
notifié la Commission européenne en
l'espèce Monsieur le Commissaire Barnier
de ce que je demandais à l'Autorité des
marchés financiers d'exercer le rôle
d'enregistre d'enregistrement et de
contrôle des agences de notation en ce
qui concerne la France nous allons
demander et vous en trouverez d'ailleurs
les références dans le courrier conjoint
qui a été envoyé par Madame la
chancelière Merkel et par le Président
de la République Nicolas Sarkozi au
président de la Commission européenne et
au président du conseil en exercice euh
monsieur van romoy pour que le rôle de
coordination pour éviter précisément que
les mailles du filet ne soient trop
lâches que ce rôle de coordination soit
bien assumé par l'Autorité européenne de
supervision des marchés pour qu'on ait
bien un un un réseau de contrôleurs de
superviseurs et d'enregistreurs qui soit
le plus harmonieux
possible alors en ce qui concerne
quelques mots rapidement euh en ce qui
concerne le FMI c'est vrai que il y
a presque 2 ans maintenant lorsque nous
avions organisé une rencontre avec le
directeur général du Fond Monétaire
International il n'était pas
envisageable d'inviter le Fond Monétaire
International à cofinancer un quelconque
plan de refinancement ou de financement
au sein de la zone euro parce que nous
étions dans une autre époque et que les
choses ont considérablement changé c'est
si vrai d'ailleurs que comme le
l'indiquait le président de la
commission des finances l'organisation
de l'Euro sa constitution dans le cadre
d'un quasi règlement de copropriété à
défaut d'un état auquel s'accrocher une
monnaie puisque c'était une construction
totalement
nouvelle ne prévoyait pas du tout euh
une quelconque défaillance puisqu'il
était intrinsèquement euh admis dans ce
pacte de copropriété que l'ensemble des
États-membres allaient un respecter les
critères de convergence puisqu'ils
étaient entrés euh dans cette dans cette
zone monétaire et que deux ils allaient
se conformer à l'ensemble des critères
qui étaaiit prévus notamment dans le
cadre du Pacte de stabilité et de
croissance donc c'est dans ces
conditions-là que d'une part il était
prévu de ne pas mettre en place de plan
de sauvetage c'est la fameuse clause de
no bailout et à forceorie il n'était pas
envisagé du tout de prévoir
l'intervention euh ni en qualité de
dessinateur d'un programme ni en qualité
de financeur ou de de cinanceur du Fond
Monétaire International ceci étant
compte tenu de l'ampleur du plan compte
tenu de la nécessité d'appliquer une
vraie technicité développée par le fond
depuis plus de 50 ans il est
parfaitement légitime aujourd'hui
d'avoir à nos côtés et en en coédacteur
du programme auprès de la Commission
européenne auprès de la Banque centrale
européenne également le Fond Monétaire
International je je voudrais pour finir
simplement attirer votre attention
sur la grande différence de situation
entre d'une part la Grèce pays
qui n'a pas de manière régulière honnête
et authentique dévoiler l'ensemble de
ces chiffres à ses partenaires ou à la
Commission européenne et ce de manière
répétée et à telle enseigne que la
confiance a été totalement ébranlée à
laquelle s'ajoutait une situation de
dette égale à 115 % du produit intérieur
brut et qui s'élèvera plus de 120 120 %
l'année prochaine un déficit supérieur à
13 % et par ailleurs un certain nombre
d'autres pays que les marchés ont
plaisir à considérer comme étant des
marchés de périphérie susceptible
d'attaque aussi virulentes que celles
qui ont affecté le marché grec je crois
qu'il faut pas tout confondre il ne faut
pas tout mélanger la Grèce est un cas
particulier les autres pays dit de
périphérique qui sont actuellement
l'objet d'attaque sont des P pays dans
des situations totalement différentes
avec des endettements infiniment réduits
par rapport à l'endettement grec et avec
une fiabilité une intégrité une
authenticité de chiffres qui ne permet
pas d'avoir de doute sur la façon dont
ils ont est comptabilisé et dévoiler
l'ensemble de leur de leur situation
donc je crois qu'il est il est
redoutable de mélanger les genres et de
comparer ou d'entraîner un quelconque
élément de de cause à effet entre la
situation d'un marché et la situation
des autres marché dernier mot enfin sur
la participation des établissements
financiers et sur le fait que ce plan
serait en réalité un autre plan de
soutien au banque c'est évidemment pas
le cas et j'ajoute que il est pas
question en l'espèce de faire de la
restructuration de faire une opération
consistante à réorganiser réduire étaler
ou ou àaisser c'est pas du tout l'objet
qui est poursuivi ici l'objet qui est
poursuivi c'est un plan de
rétablissement des finances publiques
dur rigoureux exigeant nécessaire si
l'on en croit le Premier ministre grec
et selon l'appréciation conjuguée du
fond de la Commission et de la Banque
centrale européenne et de l'autre côté
un plan de soutien au financement
permettant d'isoler ce pays pendant 18
mois complètement puis pendant 18 mois
euh de manière très très très très forte
de des risques de spéculation des
risques du refinancement sur les marchés
donc ne confondons pas les genres d'une
part pas de restructuration il n'en est
pas question deuxièmement le secteur
financier en Allemagne comme en France a
souhaité exprimer sa solidarité en
indiquant le maintien des engagements
sur la Grèce ça a d'ailleurs été
conforté par une lettre de le de
l'IIF l'Institute for international
finance qui rassemble la plupart des des
des grands opérateurs financiers qui là
aussi a exprimé sa
solidarité je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur le Ministre s'il vous
plaît merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances quelques éléments
complémentaires en codicile de ce qu'a
déjà évoqué Christine Lagarde je ne
reviendrai pas sur l'esprit la
philosophie les modalités de prêt la
logique du prêt juste rajouter sur ce
point que avoir fixer un prêt est à la
fois un message de coordination d'une
action de soutien de l'Union vis-à-vis
de la Grèce c'est aussi un message à
l'égard du gouvernement grec pour tenir
ses engagements cette logique de retour
le met dans une situation d'imposer un
calendrier précis euh des modalités de
ces réformes de structure qui sont
difficiles et qui sont douloureuse nous
l'avons évoqué mais qui euh sont
conditionné par l'octroit de ce prêt
c'est pour ça que la clause de
rendez-vous avec les Grecs est à une
fréquence régulière et c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle la clause de
rendez-vous que nous avons avec vous
nous permettra au fur et à mesure mure
de l'évolution de ce plan de bien
montrer le caractère lié de ce prê c'est
aussi un message vis-à-vis des opinions
publiques de chaque État membre de
l'Union européenne pouvoir dire que ça
n'est pas une dépense budgétaire
supplémentaire mais qu'on est dans une
logique de prêt incontestablement auprès
de l'opinion permet de mieux faire
accepter ce plan de sauvetage
qui va bien au-delà du sauvetage de la
Grèce qui va bien au-delà du sauvetage
de notre monnaie commune qui touche très
directement l'évolution de l'économie
mis des investissements des entreprises
et donc de l'emploi c'est donc un
message puissant coordonné sur lequel si
on est responsable dans une logique de
parti de gouvernement et je veux rendre
hommage aux représentants du groupe
socialiste comme nous l'avons fait à
l'Assemblée pour leur
attitude je dirais oui d'esprit de
gouvernement et de responsabilité je
veux associer dans les remerciements
naturellement le rapporteur général et
le président par extension ils ont déjà
anticipé un peu sur les débats que nous
allons avoir dans quelques semaines un
rendez-vous proche non pas à la fin du
mois mais dans la 3è semaine de mai
concernant la
conférence sur les déficits et les
finances publiques sur lequel il y aura
évidemment des annonces puisqu'il y aura
le rendu compte des rapports qui ont été
commandés sur des sujets aussi
importants que les règles
institutionnelles que les relations avec
les collectivités locales que
l'application des normes que
naturellement les programmes
pluriannuels de maîtrise des déficits
publics vous avez de ce point de vue
amorcé aussi un peu en quelque sorte le
démarrage de nos discussions autour du
débat d'orientation budgétaire et je
veux vous remercier tous les deux
d'accompagner positivement avec
l'expérience le poids et la crédibilité
qui sont pour chacune d'entre vous lié
aussi à vos expériences communes et
partagées pouvoir dire ce soir que vous
apportez un soutien dès à présent sur
l'objectif d'un plan qui n'est pas un
plan de rigueur car la rigueur c'est
l'augmentation des impôts et la baisse
des dépenses la baisse des dépenses
c'est une vision responsable qui nous
Perm permet d'être au rendez-vous de
l'exemplarité qui doit être la position
française dans la tenue de ces
engagements et d'être main dans la main
avec l'Allemagne pour orienter tous les
pays de l'Union vers une réduction
structurelle de ces déficites en plus de
la résorption des déficits liés
uniquement à l'impact de la crise trème
élément de réflexion en
accompagnement je ne doute pas que dans
les semaines qui viennent nous aurons ce
débat autour de l'approche la plus
pertinente sur la méthode concernant ces
dépenses fiscale je n'y viens pas c'est
le lieu naturellement mais ce n'est pas
le moment nous aurons d'autres occasions
pour en reparler je ve remercier Daniel
Marsin denis Badré Robert delpiquia et
Pierre-Bernard Raymond évidemment pour
le soutien qu'ils ont apporté à travers
eux et à travers les groupes qu'ils
représentent l'ensemble des formations
politiques qui se retrouvent ici nous
accompagne et me tourner vers Bernard
verra pour lui dire que évidemment je
regrette la position euh du groupe
communiste et et de
de la formation politique qu'il
représente il y a la facilité du regard
tout en respectant vos convictions mais
on ne peut pas dire que les mesures qui
sont proposées qui sont douloureuses
nous le reconnaissons tous au Grecs ne
sont pas des mesures atteignables on a
trois exemples dans l'histoire récente
de la décennie 90 qui montrent que des
plans difficiles pour des populations
permettent ensuite de sortir des pays de
lornière vous avez le Canada le Canada
était à un niveau de déficit de 5 % du
PIB en 4 3 2 années plus tard alors avec
des mesures liées à la force et à la
puissance du Premier ministre de
l'époque qui avait rassemblé autour de
lui ses 20 ministres il a dit vous
faites 30 % d'économie de dépenses
structurell dans l'année qui vient et
vous avez 15 jours pour me faire des
propositions 15 jours après il y en a 17
qui sont venus il y en a trois qu't pas
accepté les trois ont été virés c'est
dire la détermination politique qu'il a
fallu mettre en œuvre pour que le
premier ministre parvienne à ses
objectifs mais le Canada aujourd'hui est
en excédent sur le plan budgétaire un
modèle en terme de réforme de l'État sur
lesquell la France d'ailleurs s'inspire
le deuxième exemple c'est la Suède et
s'il n'y avait eu la crise elle serait
aujourd'hui en excédent alors qu'elle
avait un taux de déficit qui était
autour de 11 % du PIB et le dernier
exemple c'est la Finlande la Finlande
elle aussi était à 8 % du PIB et s'est
retrouvé dans une situation d'équilibre
progressivement c'est veut dire que les
mesures certes peuvent être diff
difficile mais ça permet aussi d'éviter
la banqueroute à des pays et de les
remettre sur une voie de redressement
durable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
nous passons maintenant à la discussion
de la motion tendant à opposer la
question
préalable monsieur ver et les membres du
groupe CRC ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 18 tendant à
opposer la question préalable au projet
de loi en
discussion la parole est à Monsieur
Michel Bou pour la motion
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je commencerai par une
citation si vous voulez bien il est
interdit à la Banque centrale européenne
et aux banques centrales des
États-membres d'accorder des découverts
ou tout autre type de crédit aux
institutions organes et organismes de
l'Union aux administrations centrales
aux autorités régionales et local aux
autres autorités publiques aux autres
organismes ou entreprises publiques des
états- membres fin de citation vous
l'urit sans doute reconnu c'est en ces
terme que l'article 123 du traité de
l'Union européenne dont la validité est
pleinement liée à la clôture de la phase
de ratification du fameux traité de
Lisbonne définit une partie des
contraintes de fonctionnement de la
Banque centrale européenne vis-à-vis des
États-membres c'est que la BCE vigilante
gardienne de la stabilité des prix n'a
pas vocation pour l'heure à venir au
secours de l'un des pays membres de
l'Union qui se trouveraiit confronté à
certaines difficultés la belle
architecture de la construction
européenne est manifestement avec ce
texte quelque peu mis en cause car comme
l'a indiqué mon collègue Bernard verra
lors de la discussion générale et
contrairement aux allégations aux
affirmations tenues par d'autres dans le
courant de cette discussion la situation
de la Grèce démontre parexemple que nous
sommes arrivés au bout de la logique de
la construction ultrabérale de l'Union
européenne prenons quelques points de
bilan l'euro est devenu la monnaie de 16
des pays de l'Union ceci ayant à un
certain moment réussi à tenir les
critères de convergence prévus par le
traité l'euro cet instrument monétaire
unique n'a pourtant jamais réussi à
devenir l'instrument monétaire commun
des 16 pays participant bien au
contraire il est devenu l'instrument de
la hausse des prix dans bien des pays et
de la dég gradation du pouvoir d'achat
des ménages il n'a aucunement réussi à
se positionner comme monnaie de
référence dans les échanges
internationaux il est devenu le
corollaire de la mise en cause des
acquis sociaux des garanties collectives
accordé aux travailleurs en matière de
santé de retraite de conditions de
travail et d'emploi comment
pourriez-vous d'ailleurs dire le
contraire quand on voit que la cure
d'austérité imposée au peuple grec déjà
victime des bas salaires de
l'aggravation du chômage constitue une
version procédure accélérée des reculs
sociaux que vous rêvez d'imposer depuis
des années aux Français qu'il s'agisse
des retraites du statut des agents
publics comme des salaires il est le
passage obligé des politiques de dumping
fiscal et social de réduction des
dépenses publiques qui sont menées dans
tous les pays de l'Union économique et
monétaire le tout avec de brillants
résultats en effet à cette heure 13 des
16 pays de l'Union sont concernés par
une procédure de déficit public excessif
procédure qui risque pour certains de
durer encore quelques temps tout
simplement parce que le caractère
récessif des choix budgétaires imposés
ne permettra pas de résoudre durablement
les difficultés seul Chypre malgré la
meurtrissure de la partition de l'île la
Finlande et le Luxembourg ce paradis
fiscal parasite en l'Europe échappe pour
l'heure à ces procédures de déficit
excessif tous les autres pays sont en
difficulté du point de vue du mode
actuel de construction européenne et
certains autres par un effet dominau
redoutable pourrait très vite se trouver
confrontés aux mêmes difficultés que la
Grèce notons d'ailleurs de ce point de
vue que si la France constitue toujours
une bonne signature en matière de dettes
publi grâce au fameux triple A des
agences de notation qui jadis surcô les
surpris les subprimes dont nous avons
parler dans notre débat notre situation
d'endettement comme de déficit public
n'est guerre meilleure que celle du
Portugal ou de l'Espagne qui constitue
depuis quelques jours les cibles de la
spéculation financière forcené qui se
mène sur les marchés obligataires et je
souhaiterais pouvoir partager
l'optimisme de Madame la Ministre à ce
sujet mais nous verrons ce que l'avenir
nous dira à ce sujet comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là la crise
obligataire que nous constatons trouve
son origine dans la forte récession
économique connue par les pays
développés à compté du premier semestre
2008 après l'explosion de la bulle des
subprimes comme à l'époque c'est donc un
segment de marché extrêmement réduit qui
est la cause d'une crise systémique dont
les aboutissements risquent fort d'être
spectaculaires cette dette obligataire
est le résultat de plusieurs phénomènes
d'une part l'accumulation des déficits
publics constatés dans les différents
pays de l'Union dans le droitfil des
politiques de concurrence fiscale et
social largement misise en œuvre des
politiques qui ont nourri un fort
chômage structurel comme la persistance
des inégalités sociales et régionales
dans l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
l'Italie a son méseau de journau la
Belgique son etau nous avons nos zones
prioritaires d'aménagement du territoire
et la Grèce à la trace la Macédoine
orientale et les pires ensuite la
nécessité de répondre aux enjeux de la
crise financière et le soutien aux
banques fragilisées par la crise
hypothécaire américaine et la crise de
confiance des transactions
interbancaires contraint d'émettre des
sommes colossales pour restaurer la
fluidité des marchés les États se sont
lourdement endettés sans revenir aussi
vite que possible dans la situation
initiale et la Grèce n'a pas été en
reste de ce point de vue l'État grec a
en effet mise à disposition de ses
banque la plupart sous contrôle étranger
cela a été très bien dit dans le débat
30 milliards d'euros soit l'équivalent
du 10e de la production nationale et
donc plus que le défaut de paiement dont
on a fait grand cas pour tout expliquer
et tout justifier enfin un facteur
aggravant la dette obligataire des états
c'est également accru des conséquences
de la crise financière sur l'activité
économique la réalité de la récession
conduisant à des baisses de recettes
fiscales et à la hausse des dépenses
d'accompagnement de la crise un pays
comme la Grèce où le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires est plutôt
faible 32 % du PIB avant le plan
d'austérité où les amortisseurs sociaux
sont fragiles et où le recouvrement des
impôts et parfois un exercice délicat ne
pouvait dans ce contexte que se trouver
dans les plus grandes difficultés cette
situation il est vrai c'est doublé dans
le cas précis d'une vaste opération de
maquillage et de trucage de la réalité
de la situation économique réelle du
pays encouragé notamment par la banque
Goldman sach connu depuis 2004 par les
services européens et notamment Eurostat
et qui n'a jamais eu l'heure de
préoccuper plus que cela Monsieur
Barroso là encore d'une certaine manière
on a laisser un pays s'enfoncer dans les
difficultés s'il fallait une preuve de
l'aggravation des choses ce serait dans
l'analyse des indices les plus récent
concernant ce qui demeure tout de même
la 28e puissance économique du monde
devant l'Argentine l'Iran ou l'Afrique
du Sud la Grèce compte fin 2009 plus de
500000 chômeurs un taux de chômage qui
dépasse les 20 % chez les jeunes et qui
est encore plus marqué dans les îles de
la merg et les régions les plus pauvres
comme la trace et la Macédoine si
l'Europe a vu un sens et été fondé sur
la coopération entre les peuples et les
états nous aurions aidé la Grèce à
disposer d'un appareil statistique
fiable et nous serions intervenus pour
donner à son administration fiscale les
moyens et les outils d'une action plus
efficace contre la
fraude ainsi dans le débat mené au
parlement grec sur le plan d'austérité
qui accompagne le pseudo plan de soutien
européen Alexandra Papariga député
d'Athène et secrétaire général du Parti
communiste grec a eu l'occasion de
souligner que
6278 contribuables fortunés étaient fin
2007 redevable de plus de 15 milliards
d'euros de dette fiscal envers l'État
grec c'est-à-dire plus ou moins 2,4
million d'euros en moyenne par
contribuable que fait-on sur cette
question qui exige-t-on rien peut-être
ne nous le voulons pas non plus c'est
donc un pays fragile bien que nos
dépourvus d'atout qui est devenue la
victime de la spéculation financière
sans réaction adaptée des instances
européennes quelle est dès lors la leçon
essentielle de la crise il est temps que
la politique reprenne le pas sur les
marchés financiers et que la mise en
œuvre des objectifs de l'Union passe par
d'autres méthodes que celle consistant à
laisser les États-membres coincés entre
les critères de convergence et les
exigences des marchés
financiers vous venez de suivre une
partie de l'examen du second projet de
loi de finances rectificat pour revoir
cette séance notre site internet
publicsenat.fr je vous donne rendez-vous
cet après-midi à partir de 16h30 pour un
cololloque sur le classement des
universités le classement de shanghï
bonne journée à tous sur Public
Sénat